okay fifteen seconds in this Hedgehog a
hilly what's a higher of them
oh god it's starting can't stop the
signal did someone say digit spinner a
dreamer says I'm [ __ ] kill me and we
monetize the Morrow's and I said the
f-word
hey make is pretty bad though um let me
see if I can fix that hi everyone that's
a onesie
okay I tried to hook up the mic is it
working
I'm working on the audio hang on I'm
trying
is it a is it recording through my
because I know there's the desktop mic
and I'm trying to go through the blue
snowball mic I'm trying to see if it's
going through their gain on it might be
a little low so I'll have to put that up
a little bit
welcome to the fabulous world of live
streaming everyone hey Joey
yes hold game reviews are coming soon
let me know if it's like like too quiet
all right am i quiet and the game is
loud
because that could be a problem
[Music]
okay
how about this so I should be louder
than the game I think
yes I'm we've only been going for about
three minutes what's my favorite Arkham
game well I'll let you take a guess
justjust look real hard at the screen
and maybe just like see what what's the
first thing that pops into your head
yeah I tried lowering the okay hold on
let me lower the game audio even more
how about that better worse shout-out to
Swift ninja what's up are you
I just want to make sure that I'm louder
than the game so that the game isn't
like everytime something loud happens in
it it's not making it impossible to hear
what I'm saying
okay um what's my favorite Batman comic
hmm you know I haven't read enough to
really uh have like iíve read a lot of
them but I don't think it's been nearly
enough Batman comics but so far the ones
I've really enjoyed were the Scott
Snyder ones you know for new 52 with
like oh wow thanks dreamer the donations
already Wow
thank you that's super appreciated I
like the new 52 thing alright let's get
started okay new game I I like how every
save file has him looking in a different
direction is this one this is probably
the least flattering angle you could
probably take a picture of Batman from
you know the other three are fine but
this one just uh just yeah I Batman
should not set this to his profile
picture on on Grindr okay
am I ever gonna do another haunted field
trip oh geez
I've gotta know I mean you don't really
go on field trips in uh in film school
so I mean I could try and go on like
vacations with my friends anyway
favorite Batman comic I've liked the
Scott Snyder stuff for new 52 I think
that whole series like all 40 whatever
issues it's had were pretty good what
difficulty should I play on
Alfred probably took those pictures and
didn't get paid to do it does Alfred get
paid at all I think like I think it's
just this unspoken agreement that he
just stays at the house
oh wow everyone's telling me to go for
Harden all right well it wouldn't be the
first time it's just been a long time
since I've played it on hard so uh bear
with me if I suck for the first few
minutes the amazing Arkham man 2 is the
best game yeah I like that one too this
is such an iconic opening everything
about this opening was just so well put
together and so well framed they did a
great job
I like the design of the battlefield
better in this game
I'm confused as to how this bridge works
to the island it's just a road that's
outlined by trees is this a man-made
bridge or did nature really just build
like a like a 20 foot by 20 foot stretch
of of earth connecting to this random
island might lower my headphones a
little it's it's really loud in my
headphones but uh how's the audio right
now because now we're like finally in
the game
[Music]
love what you've done with the place
that's Walton shop to you oh man
the the delay on this skinny hard way oh
no it's Chris Redfield okay
adios good all right warden something's
not right you know I gotta say this game
looks really great even by today's
standards graphics are just lovely I
mean even it's sometimes in the game
certain stuff will look a little wonky
with the lighting some character models
faces look a little a little unfinished
but you know it's not about graphics
it's about making a game that has like
gameplay that's memorable and unique and
the story is incomplete garbage someone
should have told Vance's of people and
they were working on Arkham Knight I've
been wondering if I should get the
remaster but I wasn't even sure if it
was like worth the amount of money
because
I was looking over it and I couldn't
really tell much difference between
certain parts of it and then others it
was just like well the lighting looks
better I don't know if it necessarily
justifies the $60 price tag to just get
the same game twice I mean I still feel
kind of dumb for getting the Uncharted
remastered edition for like the first
three games because I still have my ps3
and I still play it quite often
hey Braden mccurry what's up you were
thinking of streaming Assassin's Creed
origins any tips um I don't know I've
never played Assassin's Creed oh wow
someone donated $5 Thank You mr. so
[ __ ] this is a pretty great name also
finished the turkey sandwich trilogy
nerd okay don't worry I'll get to it I'm
working on that too yeah I've got a
couple of things I'm working on I was
waiting until I recovered from the cold
before I would start really working out
nice scripted videos yeah because for a
while every time I would say like N or
be they would sound like the same noise
and I couldn't really do narration
during that so I was gonna record the
script for the first part of the Hulk
Games retrospective and then in another
video about the new spider-man trailer
that came out did you read the Spongebob
manga no I should review a couple of new
Marvel comics they suck well yeah but
that would also require me to have to
read current Marvel comics and that's
asking a lot o Dayne with the 12 dollar
donation thanks so much man appreciate
it
oh yeah forgot Thor Ragnarok is this
week
really jump-scares
god this this survival horror game
featuring a bat main character is just
all over the place already any tips
about streaming well um being that I'm
kind of new to it myself I don't really
want to give you bad advice just be
yourself
don't send numerous dick pics key word
being numerous the real spider-man is in
chat dude Oh Josh Keaton is in the chat
that would be great I'm joking but you
know he was I wish I was friends with
Josh went 3 gone oh are you gonna
livestream Lego Marvel superheroes - I
hadn't thought about that
you know that might actually be kind of
fun I should try and see if I could find
a way to get a copy of that I'm a big
fan of how they did Killer Croc in these
games I kind of liked that he's like 19
feet tall for no reason it's way more
intimidating than if he's just a like a
normal-looking guy with scaly skin like
I didn't like he s was Suicide Squad
version of home to sexually harass don't
sexually harass your female fans is
definitely a good yeah yeah you know
with the way a way the news has been
lately maybe it's like something people
don't really know about but you know
sexually harassing people is kind of not
cool I don't recommend it but I mean if
you're a movie star and more producer in
the 80s and apparently didn't get the
memo Josh Keaton is like the most nice
down-to-earth guy on Twitter like he
doesn't talk about politics he doesn't
like shout about things he never
complains he never posts numerous
selfies he just talks to people all day
that's really cool like people send him
fan art and then they just have
discussions about it he's just really
nice and like just onesies are tongs and
after josh is a great guy thoughts on
the venom movie oh God sir doctor of
TARDIS wants shoutout high thoughts on
the venom movie I don't know man how can
you do a venom movie if you don't have
spider-man at least in the origin you
know like just acknowledge his existence
because what is Eddie Brock's character
if he's just some guy who gets the
symbiote
wonder if someone's ever like taken a
bunch of out of context sound clips for
this game for Batman a joker edited
something very sad Mark Hamill is really
cool on social media - oh yeah without a
doubt I follow him on both Twitter and
Facebook he posts a lot of fun stuff
back including like you know the
projects he's working on and random fan
photo banner photos of stuff he's been
gonna like you know behind the scenes
stuff from even like Star Wars then a
movie is gonna eat [ __ ] super hard yeah
yeah it's probably gonna I'm not in you
know you can't have venom without
spider-man just like I don't think you
can have a joker movie without Batman
because then what would it be about
hopefully sure you can have venom
stories without spider-man but having
his origin just be some guy gets an
alien suit well it's like where's the
conflict what is he worried about what's
he trying to struggle with what's he
dealing with internally he's just a dude
with superpowers at that point if they
did a Flash Thompson venom movie that
might be more interesting because you
know I think the biggest source of
Venom's problems were Eddie Brock's
problems or the fact that he has the
suit without it things are probably a
little bit easier and granted it's just
like normal people problems like that
you know paying his bills or getting a
job like Flash Thompson lost his legs
and
war struggles and alcoholism you know
there's just a little bit more human
conflict at that caught that comic we're
Deadpool got the suit first does not
Canon it is just a fun else world story
it's weird because Deadpool has become
infected with a symbiote like something
like six times and it's a different
design almost every time they do it oh
I've been looking at Chad I wasn't even
mind oh my god I forgot there's no thing
above their head that made that way
harder come on throw a punch okay I have
to remember how to do this without the
aid of the thing above their head the
Batman's spider-sense thing oh geez this
is gonna be hard I am not used to
looking at the chat hands hopping back
and forth with the game
okay that's good
it'll be cool if you turn on detective
mode and then hit someone and you could
like actually see their bones breaking
[Music]
there we go I have to remember the
controls I'm so bad at this
okay now we're getting into it okay hold
on I'm gonna get it I spoke too soon
[Music]
ow you punched that guy in the crotch
Arkham City has the best combat I mean
it's really not that different from the
first game hey Xavier
oh hi scrubs how you doing don't stream
for ten hours this time well you know I
wasn't planning on it but uh if I have
fun that's what matters
my favourite feature of all of the next
few games in this series is the fact
that you can slide at a closed event and
then kick it open and then slide into
the vent that's such a great feature and
I wish every video game ever with vents
had that huh
it's what kind of trap though Gordon
some kind of night trap here quick
activate all these traps via your
computer monitors and you have these men
and black ninja outfits constantly
falling down stairs with slapstick
comedy music but vencer spider-man's
thing I don't know man that's that's
vencer a lot of people's thing 100% the
game in one session dude last time I
tried to hunter present this game it
took me like two days very few breaks
that was back before I played video
games mostly just for a job like I don't
play video games much anymore unless
it's specifically for a video like like
I think the only two games this year
that I played through without like doing
a video for them was evil within two and
res evil 7 those were might like just
chill out and play by yourself games
otherwise it's usually I'm working on a
review or trying to do a let's play or
whatever and it's kind of hard to enjoy
games now when you're always thinking of
like how can I write a review on this
are you going to read a little stupid
chat goes too fast
spider-man equals bomb squad equals vent
dwellers should I talk to everyone like
do you guys mind if I just like talk to
all these random NPCs because I could
just skip past that hello there wait
here you can't
he'll kill Mike if he sees anyone trying
to get close he won't see me
well I ever stream Ultimate Alliance if
I had someone to play it with thank you
I would a little confused on to how this
electric chair works how do you just
give him a whiff of it like how do you
hit the button and only turn it on a
little but then turn it off like you
think it would just like immediately
shock the hell out of him in EB dead
right when it also needs some kind of
helmet thing attached how does this
chair work hold on sir how does this
chair work exactly is it specifically
for executions or some kind of strange
like like is it just for pacifying a
patient that's a little bit too too
active why do they need to be strapped
to the chair wouldn't that be what's
causing their distress I mean I feel
like if I was in a medical facility and
strapped to a chair that would
electrocute me I'd probably be freaking
out too
I don't think it's necessary I I'm
wondering if this whole thing is
actually necessarily legal like can we
get someone in here to talk about that
is it whatever what's what's up with
that well you know I guess that's a
that's a case for another day detective
Batman off to go dispense concussive
force justice al would I be he's gonna
do
something please keep them occupied
I need to get behind him
I've got to get close enough disaster
all right you'll see me coming on the
ground so I'll stay up high I can't like
how you can audibly tell when it's uh
when it's the inner monologue versus
when he's saying it out loud like they
just it just sounds different it's very
subtle alrighty then take that Nimbus
guy from the flash say I remember how
the actor who played zazz and Gotham
also played a bad guy in the flash and
thus we see the start of Harley Quinn's
descent into progressively worse costume
designs because they were like men
should we use the Jester Costume and
they're like I would look weird so they
use this and then everyone started
trying to emulate this and Harley Quinn
looked less and less like an actual
supervillain and just more like like
just like a girl at Hot Topic
you have one chance to surrender Quinn
if you guys read a Batman white night it
has a really great bit that kind of
makes fun of like you know modern Harley
versus the original version where the
Joker tries to ask Harley to marry him
after he kind of snaps to his senses and
then she starts like beating the [ __ ]
out of him and telling him that he needs
to start acting crazy again so they
could go rob a bank and then another
person who looks like Harley comes in
and then punches her in the face and
she's wearing the Jester Costume and
talks about how she was the original one
and eventually she just got kind of
tired of Joker acting like a douche and
then they swapped out and he was just so
crazy he didn't even notice well there's
there's the trophy around here somewhere
I have to get it I have to get all these
trophies for this playthrough that
doesn't need to be a hundred percent
playthrough and then and then old
Harlequin the good one talked about how
the new one is just a violent
cheerleader and is boring and then the
old one started acting like a like a
smart person and psychoanalyzing Joker
and then like talking to him like an
equal
it was interesting oh god I forgot
loading screens hold on I have a oh okay
I know you may not watch wrestling but
you could do a wrestling video game
retrospective thanks and bad gaming um
you know I don't know about that because
I where would I start when I just start
with like WWE 2001 or whatever and then
just like do roll them all the way up to
2k 17 because there's a lot of wrestling
games like um the channel two best
friends play did a Wrestlemania thing
how the hell did this happen what did I
miss I was gone for like two seconds who
blew this up the the two best friends
play channel did a thing where they did
a different playthrough or like a 30
minute quick look rather of a different
wrestling game everyday for August like
two years in a row and that's like 60
games so I it would heart be hard to
figure out exactly which ones are
reviewed are you curious about how the
venom suit is gonna look I don't know as
long as they keep the white logo on the
chest I guess I'll be happy because I'm
I've never been a fan of removing that I
also think venom looks weird with spiky
toes I think venom should just not have
toes looks weird like again it's
supposed to make him look more monstrous
like he's like so you got a weird lizard
person good it just looks kind of
bizarre
okay can I go up yet can I go up yet
listen okay I have to do this this
non-optional conversation with this
garden
you're ruining my speedrun security guy
okay here we go
yeah this is a speedrun by the way
didn't you know totally a speedrun it's
amazing how Bruce when Bruce Timm
doesn't understand Harley's character at
all even though he was her co-creator
yeah I don't know there's Harley Quinn
is a very tough case because her
character you know you can't really do
the she's just a victim of abuse thing
because she actively participates in
murder and you can't blame that on just
like her being in a bad relationship
it's it's kind of her fault she had the
option not to kill several people but
still did it anyway
hey man how you doing it's funny how the
voice actor there was Steve bloom and he
was talking to someone else named Steve
animal is a placeholder word if you want
to call someone an [ __ ] on a pg-13
thing hello there scary looking criminal
man with like a scarred up face no child
left behind when you wake up I'll
probably beat you up again in a
different part of the game all right
there's the extraction
Wehling okay Batman IRA I'm Way ahead of
you don't worry
the venom movie has some hope like
spider-man 3 did have some hope where
people start ripping it apart I don't
know I mean a via rad and Amy Pascal are
involved and that's never a good sign
look at all these dead folks I love this
foreshadowing of a different enemy type
later in the game hey you know what this
game has that uh
the other games don't really well hold
on let me show you in a second yes get
this upgrade and then I'll never use it
okay the most mature playthrough look
how mature I am everybody look at this
Xavier how his infamous second son it's
pretty good but it feels really really
rushed it could have been a lot longer
and a lot more satisfying that's what
she said
i disappoint myself um do I like Harley
Quinn and Suicide Squad
I mean she's alright I think they got a
great actor or actress to player actor I
don't know what's the PC word I don't
know what's politically correct which is
probably why I've had a lot of videos
demonetised recently um I've never been
an esse Sara Lee super into just making
sure I watch every single word there's
some pretty dark jokes in the spider-man
retrospective part one that I totally
didn't remember saying but then I look
back at it and it was like oh my god why
would I say that : let's spoil the the
surprise here haha I saw you with my
x-ray vision
a quick question is there a way to mod
this game so you can just replace
Batman's character model of midnight
does anyone is anyone good enough at
anything to do that like cuz really you
just have to kind of change the color of
the cape then change around like some
textures on the body and then switch out
the head model Xavier how do you feel
about the Ghost Rider movies
Ghost Rider one used in 2007 was a lot
cooler than it is if you watch it now
because I was like what nine years old
when I saw it back then maybe eight it
seemed pretty awesome back then then
watching it these days this is kind of
doesn't hold up oh my god
it's that enemy type from the left for
dead franchise I guess this guy spends a
lot of time on the Internet okay I have
to remember how to do this what a
strange skeleton you have there
I can't tell if those guards are dead or
not but I know they're being thrown at
me like a projectile stand over here the
Ghost Rider movies never seemed terrible
when I was watching them for the first
time but then upon reviewing them or not
not reviewing but reviewing them or
later on in life I kept thinking god
this boring man Nicolas Cage is like
really bad for this role jeez these
these these jokes are really out of
place why is it like this
quickly now come over this way here I'll
just hide around this corner so you
can't hit me
it's really weird and sad when he gets
like two steps into his run and then
just kind of comes up to a wall and he
was like oh nevermind oh oh no quick get
me a medic
he's going into heart palpitations oh
god of all the forensic science I know I
still never learn CPR this is how Jason
died then I watch the new season of
stranger things I sure did he's dead Jim
[Music]
which Robin is my favorite probably
Jason ghost you know I've heard very
differing opinions on the first Ghost
Rider movie versus the second one just
because they're so different it almost
feels like they're completely different
universes but the only common factor is
that they kept one actor it feels like
the way they would handle a sequel from
like the 80s where it's like nope no
continuity necessary just keep one main
actor and then you know hope people
don't mind like like from what like
Chucky 2 to Chucky 3 or child's play
rather those are very different movies
but they got the guy who does the voice
of Chucky to stay so you know the it's
still very jarring but um I guess if
there's one thing to like about Ghost
Rider 2 it's that all the scenes with
Ghost Rider or at least kind of cool if
not very bizarre and weird anything
about Telltale's version of Harley and
Joker's relationship I've only seen that
you're like 5 minute preview thing of
them but it's kind of cool to see that
like Harley's the one wearing the pants
in that relationship just because that's
a unique take on them on the way they
interact it's cool you have to finish
this game and deliver these pizzas oh
god not again mr. Aziz ah jeez
Joker do you like the origin for
ultimate spider-man's venom or amazing
joke oh I way more prefer the amazing
spider-man version of venom I think I
prefer six one six in most cases of
characters except for Doc Ock
I think he's cooler in the Ultimate
Universe but generally I like everything
more in the OG universe I think
have you watched at how would you handle
Dredd hood in the arkham series i would
have had his story implied to have
happened between games and have him show
up as an established character because
the coolest thing about this game and
arkham city is that they kind of
function as like games within the comic
universe like they never said when this
game was coming out that it was ooh it
was its own universe it felt like it
could have just been a random story from
the comics this game especially because
by the end of it nothing really
permanent happens all of this could have
just been a random storyline from the
comics you know Joker ends up at the end
of this game spoiler pretty beat up but
you know you could just get some new
teeth implanted heal up over a couple of
months and just go on to the next
adventure don't worry I like that this
felt like a story within the comics and
then having to redo a story from the
comics like you know Arkham Knight
trying to be Red Hood just felt wrong I
hate when they try to adapt stuff I like
original stories among comic gamers
Batman V spider-man who would win if
we're talking like just a straight fist
fight without prep time I would put my
money on Spider Man and I don't think
that's a biased thing I think that's
just because physically he's stronger
and faster and probably about equal
intelligence I mean he can build some
pretty crazy stuff
granted Batman could probably pull some
[ __ ] like pull out a device from his
pocket and it'll taste Eider man or
something but if we're talking about
like a really fair fight without Batman
you know logic lapses there's so many
times where they just go hey Geno's
Batman could totally do this oh you mean
beat darkside with two days of prep time
yeah I don't really buy that one it'd
have been funny if he got like caught in
the door and then just stuck in the the
wall who would win Xavier a skip
westcott depends on what you mean like
are we fighting physically you're I
don't know I think we'd be pretty evenly
matched
do you like ultimate carnage design more
or cyclone six being that the both times
we see carnage for the first time in
either universe he was drawn by Mark
Bagley I kind of like the ultimate
universes design a little bit more I
could see this being a continuation of
the animated series I mean it has all
the same voice actors you know I prefer
Arleen Sorkin is Harley Quinn to anyone
else because every time I hear Tara
Strong doing the voice for Harley Quinn
all I can hear are the billion other
characters from my childhood that she
played I I hear Timmy Turner I hear Ben
Tenn I hear all these characters and
even a little bit of like Raven from you
Teen Titans I I don't like it I
I would prefer someone who because you
can't listen to Arleen Sorkin voice and
then hear anyone but Harley Quinn the
character is based on her and she hasn't
had a lot of voice acting roles that
really you could compare it to who would
you put into spider-man homecoming to
villain wise um honestly I would go for
Green Goblin again except like better
this time
I like Green Goblin I think he's
underused in the movie
they they had them once and then they
halfway attempted in another time but
didn't commit fully to it you know I
feel like it was a really missed
opportunity for Harley Quinn to just
call him BM you know like Batman but
also bowel movement
I don't know if you're gonna be childish
in column names also how is she not
dying doing this it doesn't really show
it but what's her endgame when she gets
to the top of the elevator shaft
does it not just hard stop and she flies
up into the ceiling and becomes a ready
blues watch my choice for MC you doc ock
was Kevin Spacey but that ain't gonna
happen now actually I think that he
would have made a pretty good Doc Ock I
think I was taking up with his surfacing
I'm sad about Kevin Spacey cuz I really
liked him I thought he was a cool actor
he seemed like a nice guy but I guess
not here let's go we're because we're on
this 100% playthrough let's get all
these in oh you have her costume for the
profile picture in the the files but not
in the actual game what's that all about
it's 219 in England right now you're
welcome thank you so much Steel caliber
I appreciate you staying up I mean it
but it is a Saturday night at the very
least someone just typed in Josh josh is
not here he is a college I am by myself
Xavier who would you cast as venom I
think Tom Hardy would make a pretty good
venom they should try and cast him in
that role you know I think that kid that
could work out Hey look Killing Joke
reference that's a cool Easter Egg I
like that who's your favorite Breaking
Bad actor you know
Bryan Cranston is just a fantastic actor
I think he should be in more stuff I
feel bad that after I mean it's not like
he's like having a hard time finding
work or anything but after Breaking Bad
ended he hasn't been in a whole lot of
like really mainstream stuff that I've
been watching I feel like he could
really easily get a role in like a like
a DC or marvel movie or like Star Wars
or any random billion dollar project but
instead he's been going for like some
more like smaller dramatic roles like
like in that one weird indie movie about
the the crazy dragon that stomps through
San Francisco and then fights another
dragon that it's really obscure you
might might have heard of it it's um
called Godzilla III I don't think anyone
really watch that movie though it's very
obscure this is like some independent
film produced in Thailand quick question
who would you make Arkham Knights
identity if you were writing the game um
well not Jason Todd that's for sure what
is the point of this room why did I go
in here what is in here other than
Webb's what's going on am i miss
remembering things are I guess it's this
way um who would I make Arkham Knight
well you know the thing about that is
they they marketed him like he was a
character specific to this franchise
like someone who would have been special
to these games there's not a whole lot
of original characters from this series
it could have been like most of them
every time this game series introduces a
new character specific to it they die
but I don't know they seem to write a
really big check with that whole hush
Steele's Bruce Wayne's face in Arkham
City and then you know it amounted to a
two-minute cutscene in the next game
that was really disappointing so maybe
it could have been hush wouldn't have
been in a cool reveal of Batman rips the
Arkham Knights mask off and it's just
Bruce Wayne underneath and he goes
no that's impossible Bruce Wayne is a
different guy and he goes yeah whoo
he goes me and he pulls off his mask and
then Arkham Knights oh oh oh no Amadeus
Arkham Amadeus Amadeus who would I cast
his venom I already said it I think Tom
Hardy's great they they picked a perfect
guy for Bryan Cranston would be a
perfect Norman Osborn in the MC I don't
know about that I don't know who I would
cast as Norman Osborn honestly do I read
any Green Arrow comics no I do not but
I've been wanting to read that one about
the supermax prison
blasian just donated $1 thank you so
much it's very much appreciated just for
you after that I'll do this whole fight
without getting hit how about that one
so it's so far so good oh my god don't
make me look like a liar Oh
ah no no I was doing so well and then
the trophy popped up and I was like oh
hey what
hey hey you stay on your side of the
line hey your side of the line hey dude
stay your side of the line dude I gave
you half of the room why why are you
doing this
but coming over your side of the line oh
my god you were the worst roommate your
side of the it's right here you see this
line you stay over there oh my god
I was doing so well I got that 20/20
combo it was pretty good everyone was
excited at Quinn troy'd everyone was
super happy with me my parents were
happy they were proud I'll get back to
you when I was doing well in college and
then and then the drug addiction
happened and then it all went downhill I
lost all my subscribers blasian donated
another $1 thank you so much I'm sorry I
got hit I promised you I wouldn't that
is failure
Xavier what's the best corn song oh geez
don't even ask me that man it's like
choosing between your children you love
them all so much
hahaha
that's dark Xavier what would you do if
who would you cast is Harley or as Mark
margot robbie doing it fine
I think they cast a fine actress for it
block transfer Corey in every sense of
the word but I don't think they're
writing her necessarily properly
um I'm not I do not like Jared Leto's
Joker to isolate on pinch-run very much
not into it I think he's uh you know the
thing that really killed that version of
the Joker for me is the second I saw him
sitting on a boat hanging out partying
all night long with Skrillex
think of things the Joker would do
partying with Skrillex is low on the
list
don't turn around oh my god I actually
hit the wrong button hold on everyone
just like shut off your monitor for like
two seconds just pretend that just come
back at at 8:29 p.m. you know nothing
nothing happened
Xavier who would win Kevin Spacey or
skip Westcott oh dude they should do an
animated film where skip Westcott is
voiced by Kevin Spacey Jared Leto's
Joker was trying way too hard to be edgy
and think he's crazy can you do random
obscure the Dark Knight quotes okay so
I'm having a really bad problem right
now because I've been playing too much
of the other games and the controls are
completely rebec rebinding for the the
batarangs and the the detective mode so
every time I try to turn on detective
mode I throw a Batarang or every time I
try to throw a Batarang I turn on
detective mode because I've been I've
been playing on a completely different I
I was on like PS
for playing Arkham Knight I think and
then I also went back trying to play
Arkham origins a couple of weeks back
and those control schemes are so
different it's so bad I wish I could
just switch the controls out Xavier why
don't you like the ultimate universe
because it's edgy for the sake of being
edgy and they keep killing off too many
characters and they keep doing too many
stupid things you know like look at
ultimatum for example that's dumb you
know the sales get low so we need to get
rid of this storyline what do you do you
come up with a with a really annoying
awkward story where everyone is either a
cannibal or a murderer and then
everyone's either eating or killing each
other the whole story and then it just
ends yeah I know like the the main theme
of this series is exploring the
relationship between Batman and the
Joker I still don't think Joker should
have been such a giant part of Arkham
Knight do you read superheroes that
aren't big - what do you mean like not
popular ones well yeah I read Moon
Knight like I've been getting into a
character called who'll killer who's
kind of like Punisher if he had Joker's
sense of theatrics
Xavier do you watch thor ragnarok did
you like it now I haven't watched it yet
I've been a little bit hesitant too
because I don't know I'm a little bit
put off by how jokey it seems it looks
really comedy based and I'm not not on
board I mean I like the last movie the
director did I roll one of the last ones
anyway it was called what we do in the
shadows it was like a mockumentary about
an apartment full of vampires it was
really hilarious but I don't know if a
movie about Ragnarok is gonna be that
much focus on jokes is it really like is
it appropriate for the
cereal well you see that guy turned
around and I juked him that was an
amazing move people are gonna be talking
about that one for a long time whoops
uh-oh
hold on just okay all right I was gonna
try and bribe him because if anyone's
able to afford handing out bribes like
candy it would probably be Bruce Wayne
ow my throat
Xavier did you watch the new Blade
Runner movie I sure did and I liked it
oh god the lp tax is pretty bad with
this one I'm really sad that Blade
Runner 2049 did not do well at the box
office but I totally understand why it's
because that movie is not for everyone
and you know I appreciate that they
didn't try to water it down and make it
like really pg-13 or add a bajillion
action scenes or something that would be
kind of dishonest to the material they
were gonna make a Blade Runner movie and
then they did to escape I will throw a
Batarang at the wall yeah well I was
trying to turn off the Detective Mode
again I hate the way the controls in
these games switch every sequel I have
such a hard time playing one game to the
next in this series because they they
switch it up every time what the
triggers do Xavier would you think what
would you think if Tobey Maguire played
MCU Uncle Ben I think that's pretty
funny I mean it would be nice to see him
in like a more mainstream movie well I'm
gonna do the thing again just don't look
up
sir-sir just walk like two steps forward
there we go
I am window man with the power to window
interview tape hole on Joker I have to
listen these interview tapes that are
also contradicted later by Arkham
origins
remember how Arkham origins did this the
same like scene of the first time they
met and it was a completely different
version of this scene that game really
destroyed the continuity on this series
Xavier chocolate or vanilla vanilla have
you heard about the cancelled spider-man
movie that was rated R was out a thing
[Music]
yes cats and dogs is not a not a
mainstream film that a lot of people
watched I watched it I watched the hell
out of cats and dogs I can't I remember
when they've had the trailer running for
that movie uh underdog with Jason Lee
and as soon as that like before it
showed him flying it showed a whole
bunch of that trailer and I kept begging
cats and dogs two cats and dogs two cats
and dogs too and it said underdog and I
went what no no I need to find out what
happened to Milo or Lou or whatever the
[ __ ] that that dog's name was it was Lou
there we go where do I get Milo who's
named Milo there's a dog in a movie
named Milo and I can't remember who
pardon me sir I just have to ask you a
quick question how does the inside of my
glove smell oh not great apparently
Jane's camera is going to direct an
r-rated swell eye oh yeah I read the
script mint for that one where there was
all kinds of like F words
and I think electro was there but he was
an electro maybe Sandman um
spider-man woke up from from sleeping
and he was covered in webbing and it was
almost like like a like like they were
having a wet dream analog joke it was
weird
there was tons and tons of scenes of him
making out with MJ I think they had sex
while he was still wearing his mask I
could be wrong
yeah that that whole thing was weird I'm
glad they didn't go with James Cameron's
idea cuz I feel like he never actually
read a spider-man book he just had the
concept of it explained to him by a
friend and then was like I could
probably just like crap out a script for
a movie like two hours Milo and Otis
that's what it was and it's it's Marley
and Me not my lahood me remember
underdog it had Peter Dinklage before
Peter Dinklage was like really popular
and they were just like we need to have
a huh we need to have a short person
actor and he was like one of three in
Hollywood hold on I am going to fix
something invert flight no yes yes I
think I want the flight invert let me
test that out and see how that feels
well that feels way better all right
by the way there's gonna be an
all-female Marvel movie what do you
think yeah sure why not more power to
him
I kind of wish they'd have just like
given us the black black widow movie
already I feel like it's a little silly
that's taken them that long like there's
a big audience for it if Wonder Woman
proved anything you can have a female
lead superhero movie the trick is to
just not have it be a garbage movie like
Catwoman like who would have thought the
way to get people to buy tickets to your
movie and like it is to just not make a
bad movie who'da thunk what a crazy
trick ah jeez well I definitely want
this this one's cool I wish this was
like a default thing let's okay we know
what we can't afford any health upgrades
um smells like sjw's high yeah here you
get to be interpreted that way mr. bull
I mean it either means two things it
means Marvel Cinematic Universe is gonna
pull on Christian Malloy Darr you
avoiding my questions because you were
ashamed of your past animations are you
talking about Hannah may I I'm gonna be
honest with you I can only pay attention
to like a very small percentage of this
chat while also playing the game
competently which I'm not doing a great
job of if you can tell
shut up Edward your real name is Nash
Tim look look I'm such a great detective
I know what your first riddle is without
even having you tell me it I've already
found the solution it's this thoughts on
Sonic the Hedgehog oh god no but anyway
um Marvel can either be trying some new
stuff getting some new audiences which
isn't necessarily inherently a problem
it could also be the sign that they're
gonna start falling into the same trap
that the comics have been lately where
it's just like you know diversity first
story second which is unfortunate that
it's turned out that way but uh hold on
I gotta solve more riddles hold on I
know you're in a hurry and this is like
a crisis situation and like several of
your friends in this room alone are dead
but I gotta go find the Riddler riddles
I got it it's important he's not even on
the island he's not even an immediate
threat but still it's important to me
that I that I 1up this guy who thinks
he's smarter than me even though he's
never really hurt anyone directly at
this point he hasn't become a crazy
kidnap or psychopath until later Savior
did you like that venom I drew oh yeah
yeah I saw that it was pretty cool how
do you rank all the Transformers films
well um
zero transformers 20.5 Massacre
transformers five zero negative zero of
point eight transformers three oh you
know you know I just just all of them
will be below one and then transformers
one is a one out of ten Xavier would you
like Mysterio and Doctor Strange to
homecoming too perhaps to create a
multiverse with Toby and Andrew teaming
up with Tom to battle must here
that sounds incredibly convoluted and
Mysterio does not have magic powers and
that whole idea of spider spider-men no
one without was really stupid
Halon remember spider-man where it was
revealed that for several years in the
Ultimate Universe the Mysterio of that
timeline was actually just a robot
piloted by the Mysterio of the other
timeline somehow like he's a dude who
specializes in a Hollywood
special-effects but he was able to
create a portal to an alternate universe
as well as send signals through it and
remotely control androids through it and
the best thing he could figure out to do
with this amazing technology to interact
with our other timelines was to go steal
diamonds from black cat [ __ ] Bendis
man who doesn't know what he's doing I
have actually gotten all the Riddler
things in this game before multiple
times so I know where all of those are
don't worry if I skip one it's probably
just because I don't feel like going
after it but I'll probably directly look
at it to acknowledge that I at least
know where is you mean the one year in
the Ultimate Universe
takes place in will you ever do pivot
animation again no animation sucks it's
hard it's tedious Savior when the
r-rated Spiderman had a scene where
spider-man and Mary Jane had sex on the
top of the Empire State Building yeah
yeah that was that was pretty bizarre um
will you do a gameplay on spider-man ps4
when it comes out I get asked this all
the time
No or at least not until after I
reviewed it if you had the opportunity
to be cast as one character in the MCU
in the next MC the spider-man movie who
would it be and why jeez I don't know
you know fashioned myself a very
talented actor I could probably do some
voice stuff I don't really I don't
really look like a Hollywood kind of guy
I mean I'm not like like chubby or
anything but just I'm not ugly
I'm just not Hollywood pretty I don't
think they would I don't think they'd
have me Xavier would you like more
Batman fan art Shou in mine
I like fan art of all types she's well
whatever is cool by me will you divide
this in PS one into a pair of let's play
series I don't really see the point you
could just go watch the thing I was
planning on playing this for about two
hours and then cutting it off as part
one and then maybe tomorrow doing the
part tuned if I have time Joker's in
control of the island he's responsible
for sending you over here surprise Joker
didn't send them all into like some kind
of giant meat grinder that he had the
Riddler build like prior and like just
like it the floor opens up and they all
start falling in help no you and your
men are safer here
do I like Ezra Miller as the flash I
don't know if I have the authority
really to say whether or not he'd be a
good flash since I don't read any flash
comics but from what I've seen of him so
far I don't mind him he seems alright
he's kind of a goofy stoner sort of type
and seeing interviews with him is really
hilarious because he has a hard time
screaming a sentence together but he can
read his lines pretty well I'm outside
the Arkham mention Harley Quinn probably
triggered the alarm
if you stole a spider-man we don't post
spoilers in the chat for comics yes I
did read that one actually spectacular
spider-man number six
read it yesterday I even tweeted about
it other people might not have seen it
in the chat yet so be a little bit more
careful about spoilers Xavier if you can
pick a comic book into a movie woe to be
I'd want a Moon Knight movie really bad
moon nights so cool and no one ever
gives him any
kind of appreciation who would I cast
his moon night I don't know is James
McAvoy busy he could probably get in
really good shape I'm just gonna where
were you again come on there we go now I
won't get shot
be really funny if I landed on the
barrels and they all just came tumbling
over making a shitload of noise and
Savior do you like spider-man the new
animated series the 3d one yes I do I
think it was really cool I just wished
that it had gotten more episodes and
didn't end on a really horrible
cliffhanger how about a moon night
Netflix show I don't know I feel like
maybe Netflix shows they'd start to feel
a little bit samey after a while if they
did a moon night one they'd have to do
something very special about it to make
it stand out although like if they did
like a network show and then like kind
of handled it the way they handled
Legion where it's a little bit abstract
and talking and playing is really hard
really abstract and lots of like weird
reality warping stuff it would be pretty
cool wow that was cool moon
think I'm getting the hang of this again
oh my god every time every time every
time I say I'm doing good I stopped
doing good ii oh my god
who's your favorite voice actor for
spider-man behind besides Josh Keaton or
just do you mean in general in the trunk
of the Batmobile I may need it
hey skull ah X don't worry you're not
late we're we're still on we're gonna
keep on trucking for another hour here
probably Xavier which is better
spectacular a 90 Spider Man and why and
take out the aspects of this fight 90
Spidey not punching anything um I mean I
like that the 90s one was a little bit
more comic accurate but there are
certain parts of it that just felt way
too cheesy to me I don't know I prefer
spectacular still it just felt too
perfect you know I like that the
storyline was able to run from one issue
to the next oh yeah I gotta go to the
trunk not one issue what am I talking
about
ah this is so weird just having to talk
when nobody else is in the room but
still you're talking to I'm 53 Petey
come on please answer happy and I later
I am afraid I missed your question
because I was looking at the game oh did
I see the video of Evan filar catching
me for the spider-man three swinging
thing yes I'm well aware that that
review I could have done better
i that that was a big goof on me that
was probably my least favorite review
I've ever done is the spider-man 3 thing
is because I screwed up with the
complaining about the web-swinging
because I had only played the game one
time by that point and I just was having
such a bad time that I didn't want to
pay a whole lot of attention to it so I
missed the part of the tutorial that
explained how to gain more altitude
while swinging and I complained in the
review that you don't get altitude very
easily I still think the game is garbage
but
I will submit that I [ __ ] that up and
that was my fault
Xavier what I want to be a beyond Batman
Batman Beyond Terry McGinnis game yes
that would be pretty cool I kind of hope
Rocksteady does that next if they're
gonna not do more Batman stuff there
Batman current stuff
hey stop foreshadowing the ending of the
game you guys what exactly are you like
nailing down I feel like you're just
hitting a piece of wood with a hammer
sir what are you doing do you think Mark
Hamill would make a good live-action
Joker
he'd have okay Joker is a very skinny
guy and even though Mark Hamill's in a
lot better shape than who was 10 years
ago he'd have to slim down a lot but you
know he'd at least have the voice on
lock down he'd also be an older Joker
for sure cuz he's like what 60 there's a
Batman Beyond game on ps1 it's terrible
oh yeah that's kind of the general rule
is a Batman game before like 2005 is
most likely terrible hold on sir I just
wanted to just uh just gonna ask you a
question how does this glove smell does
it smell like chloroform still okay geez
I've washed my hands several times it's
just not coming out on what it what if
Batman's doing like the cutesy boyfriend
thing where he puts his hand over this
guy's face and goes gasps whoo oh oh no
he hit it oh god that was way more
violent Willem Dafoe is Joker yeah I
could see that that would be cool again
you'd have to go for an older Joker but
then you know the whole point of
batfleck Ben Affleck's Batman is he
supposed to be a little bit up there in
his age so probably wouldn't
would be - how would you compare EMH to
Wolverine and the x-men xanimation he's
trying to take over the eyes do you mean
like in terms of animation they've
looked kind of similar I thought it was
weird how everyone in Wolverine and the
x-men had really bulky ankles torn apart
throw it in the water how would you
write skip Wescott into a good
spider-man movie I would not because
that's horrible I'm not a bad person I
mean I I skirt the line but I feel like
I'm not that terrible Willem Dafoe is
such an obvious choice - yeah yeah
Ziggler would you want a Clone Saga
movie
I think the Clone Saga could be pretty
damn cool if done right because a lot of
people don't ever give like the
storytelling aspect of Clone Saga like a
you know if you try and analyze it
deeper than just here's a bunch of dumb
[ __ ] that happened I do think that
there is some merit to it because oh my
god uh hold on let me focus on this
fight before I actually praise the Clone
Saga cuz that's not an easy thing to do
okay I'm doing okay so far oh [ __ ] I
killed that guy he died did I win
where did he go oh my god is he like
that game show contestant that fell
behind the obstacle course and they
never found him oh my god is he down
here where did he fall everyone saw that
right am I crazy guys that guy fell I
murdered him I murdered two guys oh no
my bat conscience Xavier would you like
a spectacular or would you do a spider a
spectacular spider-man series review I
don't know what would I say about if
that if you don't already know I mean
yeah it's great
here let's go in here cuz it's an
additional cutscene do I think Ben
Affleck is doing a good job as Batman I
wish he had a better script to read from
but I think so
I think he's an all right choice hey
what's up
where's Gordon hmm
you know Gordon is there something wrong
with your voice
normally you sound like Mike Ehrmantraut
from Breaking Bad why do you sound so
different this time around hey Xavier
back to Clone Saga okay so I want that
interview tape the Clone Saga was an
interesting addition to the Spider Man
Laura in my opinion because it showcased
the idea of what if spider-man became
really jaded and depressed and like lost
his sense of hope and his sense of humor
everything that made him more
light-hearted what if he just was faced
with so many dark things that he lost
lost that that innocence as a hero so
you get that storyline where a Joker and
chameleon work together to make Peter
think his parents came back to life even
though they didn't just purely to screw
with him that's pretty pretty messed up
with them but then Peter kind of like he
gets pretty down on himself after that
one happens but then the shock of
finding out that those two people were
Impostors puts Aunt May in the hospital
right
like almost for good like she's like
really really doomed this time so
Spiderman kind of goes nuts because
everything in his life seemed to be
going really great for a little while
even things with like MJ and then hurt
him and her start having problems
because you know he started getting more
and more crazy so she left so he became
kind of this jaded depressed psycho who
runs around calling himself the spider
he doesn't wear his coffin he doesn't
take his costume off except to like
shower he only goes home to eat and
sleep and then spends the rest of his
time outside swinging around bashing
people's faces in like he still doesn't
break his killing rule but he's kind of
gone off the deep end and is acting more
Punisher II than usual so it's like she
shows paws spider-man losing himself and
what Ben Riley represents more than just
dumb idea he shows back up and Ben Riley
represents what spider-man was like five
years ago in terms of the story cuz
because Ben Riley was created five years
prior in reality it was like something
like 12 years prior in a storyline that
introduced the Jaqueline in which you
know spider-man how to fight a clone of
himself and then he thought he died and
then had to get rid of the body but he
was wrong but anyway Ben Riley
represents sort of this innocence that
spider-man had now lost and okay let's
see if I can get to this guy in time to
uh why is the glide thing not working oh
my god I whatever that worked still all
right but uh he shows up and he's you
know he's spider-man without a lot of
the baggage he's you know certainly has
a lot of the memories prior to Ben Riley
has a lot of the memories prior to him
being you know cloned but for the most
part he hasn't really experienced a lot
of really terrible things he's just been
kind of having a struggle with the
concept of being not a real person but
he's not he's not like a really
depressed crazy psychopath he's he's
kind of a okay guy and even handles
things differently from Peter in an
interesting way like like for example
Ben Riley is like men how his venom
still running around and spider-man
hasn't like stopped him I should
actually like do it once and for all so
he he you know despite having a lot less
combat experience ends up beating venom
in a one-on-one fight and that was cool
because he invented like a new type of
web shooter to do it but basically when
Peter and Ben start interacting Peter
immediately beats the [ __ ] out of him
screaming I hate Peter Parker because
he's a crazy person and like almost
kills him but then later they they start
talking and Ben Riley goes if you hate
your life so much I will gladly take
because being a fake person is kind of
shitty and you know that's that's an
interesting note is that Peter Parker
complains about his life all the time
but what what does that mean to someone
who is like a weird kind of not Peter
Parker like a a shadow of his existence
Ben would totally want to deal with all
the same problems did I get two guys
with that or no okay Ben Riley would
love to have the kind of problems Peter
Parker has other that you know instead
of dealing with the whole I'm not a real
person thing so it kind of it kind of
humbles Peter in a way where he has to
think about oh geez I thought I could
sneak up on him
pardon me everyone I'm just gonna hop
over this ledge look the ragdoll in this
game is amazing Ben Riley reminds Peter
Parker of the best parts of himself and
how other people see him
this kind of childlike wonder and this
this sort of steadfast I'll never give
up on what I believe in kind of thing
that makes him so inspiring and Ben
Riley in a sense teaches Peter Parker
had to be himself again by being an
exact copy of himself before he became
an [ __ ] and I think that stuff is
cool if you strip down the story to that
basic idea it's a really cool idea you
don't need all this extra complication
of like which clone is which you know it
is Ben Riley the real Peter Parker and
Peter is not you know it didn't then
there's also the the pregnancy that
doesn't work out with MJ all that stuff
is unnecessary oh my god I just want to
climb over the ledge why does it bog he
did the stupid front-flip thing I'm so
mad
okay I'll just hide under this is floor
great see is seeing a second one okay
hey Veronica love our cram Jane Parker
is kind of cool it's just like well he's
almost fits in is like an extra version
of that like what if Peter Parker went
even further down the line and just kept
being an [ __ ] and then didn't fix his
behavior like what if he just had no
responsibility and no sense of right and
wrong he just did what felt best for
himself because Kane became like a
serial killer for a little while and
like a mercenary and all kinds of bad
stuff so he can fit into the story you
don't have to cut Kane out I am I think
the part that really killed that story
was trying to introduce the concept of
Peter being a clone and then being the
real one because that contradicts so
much logic and it's such a you have to
do so many narrative gymnastics to make
her make it make sense so I think the
Clone Saga would make a cool movie if
you took out that part where they tried
to make it all ambiguous and be like is
he or isn't he oh that's a different
part of the floor damn I thought that
was this one well I can still probably
just like sneak up behind this guy and
come closer so I can grab you and choke
you out okay thank you
Xavier are you telling me Spyder side
wasn't the greatest huh no man spider
side was the best idea he's just such a
great oh my god
see this is what happens when you bring
up spider side how do you feel about the
route Marvel Comics is going down you
made me very tired and sad by asking
that question look it like I was having
a really great night then you asked me
how I feel about current Marvel Comics
not not going great
hey look I turned on Detective Mode
without throwing a Batarang first gonna
do the thing it's gonna be so cool wait
did I buy that upgrade okay I did save
your how do you feel about Myles 616
counterpart in spider spider-men - I
haven't read all the way through
spider-man - I've only read up to the
third issue I think spider-man is
spider-man one is really good spider-man
two is infuriating because I feel like
Bendis is at the point where he's
flat-out forgotten how to tell a story
over the course of multiple issues
because for the first two issues no new
information is gained and the reveal of
what the alternate universe Miles
Morales is like is super underwhelming
like he flubbed both the you know
concept of like giving more information
every scene it felt like there are
several scenes in there that were just
like characters talking but not really
getting anything across that was useful
um the the big reveal at the end of the
first issue was really annoying because
it just it was just so underwhelming
like I feel like it didn't need to be
there like it could have been way later
and have more impact it's just uh can I
scoot through here holy [ __ ] I can I
thought my giant wide bat shoulders
would allow me
I'm gonna put a trap here hey guys I
said the word trap now everyone can go
on a whole rant about that one thing
Xavier get them in the polls with what
sorry I'm late I just got back from
Ragnarok oh cool hey how you doing man
what's up why is someone yelling at
someone named Megatron Xavier what do
you think of the new venom film that
will underperform at the box office and
get terrible reviews and be rebooted
over and over until they sell the rights
to Marvel Studios well you know I feel
like it'll underperform at the box
office and get really terrible reviews
and probably be rebooted over and over
until they just sell the rights to
Marvel is what I think will happen to it
trap room oh you watch that video wow
that's great I like to rile up the
criminals sometimes by throwing a
Batarang if they're at their nether
regions get him real mad oh oh hold on
can I do this I'm gonna do this thing
I'm gonna do it
are you gonna watch olive beware the
batman I will when I can get a way to
watch it oh my god so many explosions
quickly run up the stairs and go solve
the problem big strong strong criminal
man there we go now I did it movie man
mad production says I'm dead on the
inside yeah I know how that feels man
thoughts on the Black Panther trailer
are you excited I don't know I'm kind of
I'm at the point where I'm just a little
bit bored with MCU movies like am I like
some we had a weird terrible person just
because like I'm not that excited for
them anymore they all kind of feel the
same the action scenes are kind of
underwhelming it's just not that into it
I mean I wasn't even sure if I was gonna
see Thor Ragnarok but a lot of people at
school have been telling me that it
ain't terrible you know I feel like the
Riddler if he wanted to uh if he wanted
to
you know express his intelligence a
little more he could have gone gone for
some more highbrow humor than dead baby
jokes he could have he could have
probably just googled this one you're a
terrible person but it's not the MCU
thing affair that's true
I'm excited for the Hellboy reboot oh
you know after they talked about how
they cast cast David Harbor in that role
by the way you know that I've always had
some questions about this why is this in
this office
who did this and why I mean this is a
mental hospital
what's the point of this why on earth
would anyone do this this is horrible
why hold it shut up you you down there
I'm busy you if you can give me an
explanation for this I'll help you who
did this and why
why is this a thing that's happening no
over here I'm looking right at get over
here why are you just standing there oh
my god
oh Jesus Christ okay um
is that all right there's no prompt it
just activates when you stand a certain
part well I know it's an unused
character's head but why how is that an
easter egg it's soul or breaking and
weird no hospitals should ever have a
sever it this is that's something out of
like outlast these are supposed to be
like good people I'm helping this doctor
isn't supposed to be like a like a
serial killer these are supposed to be
civilians okay stay here this this this
nurse voiced by Steve bloom like what
why all right let's go check out that uh
killer croc thing nice uh yes I get that
a lot what is Riddler one of my
subscribers yeah man he was uh he was
thorough
but for a tea game I'm kind of surprised
it took all the way to the third one for
it to just finally be classified as an M
anyway what was I doing again oh yeah I
got a rescue the doctors I kind of like
to imagine that some of the things that
I'm saying Batman says out loud like
what was I doing again which do you
prefer a CEO Peter Parker High School
Peter Parker I prefer post-college
working a job that's not terrible Peter
Parker I liked when he was a
schoolteacher I felt that was very
fitting for him you know like he could
pay his bills he had a wife he acted
like an adult instead of some kind of
weird deranged manchild man look at
those Cape physics isn't that and that's
something
and I'll throw you over there and end by
punching you in the crotch ha ha
in that little weird that Batman sits on
this dude's a head like just gives him a
face full of bad ass and then just
punches him as hard as he can in the
crotch it's a little bit weird Bruce
then again you know Bruce has got some
problems I mean if you've seen who I
hate dresses you know I'm excited for
the Hellboy reboot because I thought
Hellboy 2 the Golden Army was poop was
boring and lame I didn't like it that
much but the first one was great
probably one of the best superhero
movies of all time just because it was
able to introduce such a bizarro concept
with such finesse without doing an
annoying way pardon me doctor I just
need to get this trophy
right
I think they cast a great guy for the
reboot David Harbour I mean I didn't
quite dawn on me just like watching his
stuff before but all throughout stranger
things - every time he did anything all
I could do was just imagine what if he
was Hellboy his voice sounds really good
for Hellboy he has the right face for it
just like the the you know the shape of
his head he's about the right size
I could totally imagine some of the
things he's saying as like Hellboy lines
how did you not get crushed to death by
falling debris
shouldn't this have what there's a
corpse behind you and you're standing
like ankle deep in rocks
how did none of that hit you bizarro is
better hero than the injustice Superman
yeah my dad thinks daredevil is satanic
well you should tell him that he's
actually probably one of the most
religious superheroes out there he's
like super Catholic hey Xavier what's
the deal with contests - slashers well
um in what context like is it still
coming out if so yes
you know we don't ever hear in voice
acting anymore pre-summer I feel like I
don't hear her anymore I rescued you
first and now well searched I don't
think it's for the best I guess she was
one of those voice actresses where every
time she talked in anything all I heard
was number five from kids next door I
had this really bad problem with voice
actors where if I remember something
else they've been in that's all I can
hear when they talk so it just takes me
out of the story I'm gonna get all of
these Joker teeth things alright
out my cat just decided to scratch my
legs
ah you see well the reason why is
because I still have a hole in my jeans
from that time I had that freak out on
the on the on the driveway about Amy
Pascal I ripped a giant hole in my pants
and in the knee area and it still got
strings hanging out my cat occasionally
runs over and just decides to go play
with it very painful sure are a lot of
dead folks in this here hospital can we
get another turkey sandwich video I
don't know that first one was hard to
film did the battering thing again very
upset with myself how do I I thought I
had enough time okay damn you Amy Pascal
damn you yeah was that it was that thing
um like how Mac from Foster's home was
uh yeah yeah I remember that he was um
spider-man in the the other thing I
think guys Josh Keaton was able to not
bug me about it do during splatterhouse
because it was such a different
character from Peter Parker I mean he
was just talking so differently like the
character and splatterhouse just cusses
constantly so it was hard to hear
spider-man in that because like you
don't hear Spiderman telling someone to
shut the [ __ ] up constantly so it was
kind of fun a good spider-man movie idea
would be a Cravens last hunt yeah that
would be cool I remember there trying to
do that for amazing spider-man 3 or they
thought about it um I think part of the
reason Cravens last hunt works is
because like there's a reason why Kraven
goes absolutely insane first because
there's like years and years of him
trying to catch spider-man and not
able to do it it kind of falls a little
bit on its face if it's the first time
these two characters meet you know like
like he's just some crazy guy who
kidnapped spider-man if they had some
history together
would be better what do I think of Henry
Cavill Superman I think he's great um he
has a great voice for Superman whenever
he talks he sounds kind of like Tim Daly
or the other guy ha ha I think I killed
that guy actually well I can't let him
dive
no one says I have to say you know I'm
Batman I I have the option to just say
I'm not gonna kill you
but I don't have to save you and then
just leave the train
you know I'm allowed to do that that
doesn't count as murder
but anyway Henry Cavill I think he's I
think he's a good Superman he looks like
him he sounds like him he's got some
some good on-screen charisma I think
that he could use some better script
writing along with a lot of here's the
thing I'm not mad at a lot of the
casting in the DCE you I think Joker is
is the only one that really bugs me
everyone else I think fits their roles
pretty well well maybe not Deadshot that
very clearly tried to make him more of
an important character than he actually
should have been because they're like
well we got big name Bruce Willis some
bruton a brutal brutal Will Smith wow
those are very different actors how do I
get those mixed up anyway they got Will
Smith to play him and they're like well
it's you know we can't have him have
like three lines in the movie you don't
cast Will Smith and then not use him
what would you want dared oh okay
Godzilla Mendoza would you want
daredevil as a mentor for the next
spider-man sequel in the MCU maybe as a
teacher for Peter for fighting and
learning his spider sense I just want
them to interact at all I mean I kind of
like the em I think spider-man doesn't
need them
mentors I'm kind of tired of them
constantly trying to give him a dumb
father-son relationship with other
superheroes just stop trying to do the
surrogate father things let him be his
own man let him be his own guy he
doesn't need to give a [ __ ] with Ironman
thinks there's teeth around here I hear
them I need to find them him and
daredevil are friends they're buddies I
like that better okay there we go hey
what's up how you doing guy from that
one comic book extrude at freak Street
where he belong Savior mind the only one
that thinks totally the buyer spider-man
has aged terribly to the point where his
performance is bad I don't know I don't
think it was bad I mean I it's been a
long time since I've watched those
movies so maybe I should check it out
but another thing it's bad hey this guy
land on to get at this angle whoops did
the thing again are you dead
oh my attempt to be murder Batman didn't
work
hey guys everyone look I'm written by
I'm written I'm written by his neck
Snyder oh I killed this innocent man
with this Batarang
it's actually just a throwing star I
threw it at his throat he's dead
Zack Snyder killing everyone I'm gonna
brand him so when he gets into prison
he'll get killed immediately even though
that was ripped off from Moon Knight
Xavier do you think Dan Slott will ever
leave spider-man like ever well one
could hope that eventually he'd just get
like tired of it and then like retire
but I kind of feel like he won't because
he's stubborn and he think he's he's
very pretentious so he thinks he's a lot
better writing this stuff than he is
he's like why would I ever want to leave
I'm I might my stories haven't declined
in quality they're better than they ever
were
she asked me he should have stopped it
spider-verse
cuz I was not a big fan of spider-verse
but you know other people liked it
it's not necessarily always about what I
like but if other people enjoyed
spider-verse than sure whatever ah geez
I'm totally turned around now I have to
look at the map again it's in it's in
here okay all right that's that's all I
needed thank you you don't have to you
don't have to turn my head for me to go
look here let's just go down this way
is there another trophy in here that I'm
missing or no do you like spider-man ps4
white spider you know I don't mind it
you're gonna do another version of
spider-man's costume that's the way to
do it
oh look hush
references gee I wonder what's gonna
happen when I walk to the other side of
this room don't speak you're safe now
what kind of thing is this a thing that
exists in real life this contraption for
surgery who built this does this exist
in this film ROM Schneider is a stapler
and this other one he's a cookie
okay hold on I'm gonna get this I'm
gonna start getting good at the combat
again not doing terrible so far except
for those times I get hit but though
those didn't happen
those were hallucination damn it okay
sir you are getting severely tea-bagged
after this fight is over I don't care if
it's childish no one's watching except
Joker and he encourages that kind of
behavior wonder what would happen if
Batman just started doing something
really bizarre and childish and stupid
and then Joker was like Mario's like hey
that's pretty cool he started like
egging him on like yeah keep going dude
save your thoughts on Dark Knight
Returns three the master race I haven't
gotten past the first Dark Knight story
I thought it was good but then I
everyone kept telling me that Frank
Miller started to lose his [ __ ]
although speaking of Frank Miller you
know I have been reading some of the
Wolverine books that he drew he was a
lot better at comic art in the eighties
pikin in that first Wolverine like for
issue series I was like man they should
they should totally make this into a
movie and then I realized oh wait they
did it was called The Wolverine and I
was surprised how many scenes they just
took straight for it
like that part where he fights a bear
and then goes all boy some some
douchebag hunter gave this bear a poison
arrow and he goes and finds them and
beats him up in a bar they use that
scene that was cool I didn't like that
silver samurai instead of just being
like like a normal guy was instead
converted into a giant crazy Iron Man
robot
I feel like Ironman kind of ruined
supervillains for a short time because
they decided that every supervillain
needs to look like Ironman
you know shredder is running around in
robot suit Rhino is running around in a
robot suit silver samurai is in a robot
suit because it's like an easy way to
have a guy in a suit not necessarily
just be like silly-looking is you could
just make him look like he's an Iron Man
role but the new Spider Man TV show
sucks yeah well yeah I saw one episode
how do I send you some fan art and stuff
I've done well you can send it on my
discord server which I believe is in the
description yeah probably yeah it is you
can also send it to my Twitter people
send me fan art on there all the time
those are the two best ways you won't
stand a chance Frank Miller used to be
great but then after his masterwork of
Sin City he went off the deep end well
you know use some of it I think his uh I
don't want to sound like like a young
punk going wah well he's he turned old
so he went crazy no thing some of it I
gotta start to wonder his has something
to do with his age I mean he's he hit a
certain point and then it just seemed
like everything started to take a hit
but again he's also very sick you have
to keep in mind he's like I can't
remember what he has specifically but
there's something that prevents him from
being able to draw as well as he used to
it I think it's like Parkinson's or
something of that nature
something pretty rough oh my god I was
just trying to do the thing how'd you
turn around so fast
I'll just hop over this legend oh my god
okay the way that happened it looked
like he landed and just broke his ankle
I want a Batman story where he acts like
he'll with the players of the Arkham
games play so he's super obsessed with
solving Riddler puzzles that have
nothing to do with the main problem at
the story that'd be great yes they're
safe I need to get a Xavier how do we
donate my research well you can uh you
can donate through my patreon which is
linked in the description
there's also Oh Dane page five I'm so
excited there's also a way to stone a
through a live stream which I've never
done before cuz I don't really have
money but other people have been doing
it all night and they I'm pretty hit I'm
pretty happy they're very nice people
thanks everyone who's donated so far
you're all great people and I appreciate
all I guess but at the very end I'll
give you all a big shout out all right
I'm gonna try and stealth this without
getting seen and/or hurt I think I can
do it
I'm gonna attempt to turn on detective
mode without throwing a Batarang ready
okay that's step one of seven completed
uh so far so good oh come on
ah man I almost fell into that vent
after I died why did you pick your
youtube name I told this story a couple
of times um while my mom was pregnant
with me and she was trying to like you
know spit ball names with my dad he was
like hey what if we named him Godzilla
she's like that's a terrible idea and
then it never came back and they never
talked about it again
yes until I was 10 and I was like dad I
want to start a YouTube channel cuz I
love YouTube and I want to make cartoons
and stuff and he I was like what do I
have B my name he's like well you know
you could be named Godzilla Mendoza
which could be like a reference joke to
this thing and and then I said sure and
then that's how that happened oops okay
here we go
now I'm gettin it step 1
turn on Detective mode yeah yeah it's
step 1 it's it's the hardest part really
never a little uh yeah you know you
never uh don't have enough time to do a
laugh you riddles in the middle whoa
whoa whoa I didn't intend for that to
rhyme riddles in the middle but you know
sometimes these things they just turn
out that way
here I'll just put explosive gel here
for no reason
oh my god it would be so great if that
guy came over here maybe I can get him
to come closer by making noise quick
come check out this area it'll be great
just you over there get over here check
it out it'd be a really great idea if
you decide to just walk over here just
just come check it out guys I do I can't
afford the sonic Batarang yet come on
it's it'll be great just just take a
look-see here plenty of noise go figure
out what that is what's that clanking
noise boy it sure is funny how I have
this many batarangs come on guys work
with me here please and these are the
worst criminals ever you know what their
greatest crime was not giving me the
attention I deserved whatever they ended
up in prison for that's excusable not
paying attention to me that is worthy of
death okay I'm gonna attempt to sneak up
on this guy hello boy your buddy sure
has bad hearing the sound of me hitting
you in the back of the neck was really
loud do you eat McNuggets sauce not the
one do you mean the McNuggets sauce that
everyone acted annoying over no I
haven't eat that sauce Xavier used your
bat snacks to lure them to you of course
why didn't I think of that I could I've
got plenty of meow Mix in my in my
utility belt for Selena I could have
just used that maybe like hey this is
this meow Mix why is this here in this
mental hospital and some other guy would
be like there's a lot of weird [ __ ] in
here man there's a jar with a severed
head on the other side of the room and
then the other guy would be like no that
there's no way that's too crazy even for
this place then they get into a huge
argument with it oh hey my cats here oh
he's doing the thing with my knee again
please stop oh I love you so much monkey
but you're such a bad cat I'm so even
step one
turn on detective mode or that throwing
a Batarang at pool all Savior what are
your thoughts on pickle Rick boy did
people sure figure out how to make that
annoying Rick and Morty is the new meme
pool Savior how would you feel if they
made a batman arkham live-action series
like a TV show
that'd probably be pretty cool I think a
Batman TV show as a NEET is a neat
concept although it's kind of annoying
that they're like hey let's do a Batman
TV show but like have every aspect of
Batman except Batman himself in it
[Music]
anyone remember those i'm a marveland
i'm a DC videos yes 2d swirl i watch the
hell out of those as a kid i love those
that guy it's just some random guy on
youtube was one of the guys who inspired
me to get into making youtube videos
what I like the defender is an infinity
war why do you have two caps like that
yes I sure would I'm not like is like
major characters but at least is some
kind of uh some kind of Easter Egger or
at the very least just a small scene
with them like fighting Thanos his
forces on the street just to acknowledge
they exist
you see why I zoomed in on that was not
for any particular reason other than I
think actually the button to detonate
those in another game is to do this but
clicking the stick
what am I crazy is there a game where
you detonate those by clicking in one of
the sticks I really feel like there is
God what what am I getting these
controls mixed up with that's messing me
up so bad we're you're gonna hear him
you're gonna hear me get killed by my
cat and the stream will just be an
awkward silence yeah yeah I could see
that happening boy am i my knee
it just looks like Deadpool's face right
now it's just so clawed up he's been
doing it all day III should probably
like do more than just just push him off
and go out oh no we have to save Mike
Ehrmantraut in Arkham Knight it
detonates with the steak okay I am
getting Arkham Knights controls and also
Arkham origins controls very mixed up
with this game I'm having a real hard
time would you prefer the Batman V
Superman Fighter Captain America and
Bucky versus Iron Man um I don't know I
like the Batman V Superman fight
although I think it could have ended a
little better oh no we're her his
glasses he can't see without his glasses
I'm sorry you know if if I have the
reaction to the bomb squad thing that I
do how do you think the Rick and Morty
guys feel about pickle Rick I bet they
hate it like they'll pretend they aren't
annoyed by it and interviews just so
they don't like piss off their fan base
because Rick and Morty fans can be very
themselves but I bet they they hate it
Barbara there's this thing on the floor
is this is this a fluorescent light
fixture that fell down or a vent or what
is that what's what's with all these
like chains and [ __ ] why do I have
Luther strode eyes left for dead
retrospective be rather short there's
two games and this one the group is
these characters and the gameplay is
like this but in the second one the
gameplay is like like slightly different
and these characters are there oh boy
that's a lot of bugs stomping sounds
does anyone remember the old days when
g4 used to play all kinds of video game
stuff
I remember they did this thing called
first 15 that I really liked where they
they would play the first 15 minutes of
most games just to like give you like I
here's what it looks like but they they
couldn't do the first 15 minutes of this
game because most of that is just
walking around and no combat so they
chose this section instead oh God
this is this is what I hear whenever I
take my headphones off I feel like
something doesn't want me here but I'm
just I can't figure out why I'm getting
that feeling right
you know for some reason I feel like I
shouldn't be in this room yeah you know
just as well I could probably just come
back here like right now for example hmm
this room seems a lot less schizophrenic
II now then when I entered it a second
ago
I also don't remember this room leading
back to itself that's a little strange
oh my god
it's negan from Walking Dead favorite
Halo game either halo 3 or Halo Reach
oh my god it's Maggie from Walking Dead
[Music]
hey guys mm-hmm
do you know who this is everyone who is
this who's this character right here
it's Martha anyway I'm gonna go over
here so that's what Robert Downey jr.
went after Iron Man 3 yeah kinda
favorite DC character hero or villain I
really like mr. miracle I've been
reading some a Jack Kirby's old mr.
miracle comics from the late 70s and
those are really cool like a
super-powered escape artist slash like
guy who escaped from Darkseid's
Apokolips
Martha why did you say that name oh no
it's the main character of 28 days later
wasn't really a jump-scare because like
you see him and Danny pops out man this
is such a ripoff of the Mysterio boss
right from spider-man shattered
Dimensions it's basically exactly like
this also evil within to which I just
got done playing yesterday had a scene
almost identical to this except you were
hiding from the view of a camera
oh my god I'm scarecrow why am I scared
of myself scarecrow has bad self-esteem
alrighty then I'm just gonna go over
here I'm just gonna
hey Bab in you know you don't have to
make it a bat symbol every time I mean I
know it's like cute and stuff and it's
like like silly but you don't have to
you could just make a big blob
Scarecrow could you um not look over
here nothing to see here man nothing
nothing to value over this way okay just
gonna whoops oh oh oh my god how did you
not see me boy thou is like the best
love ever because I got away with it
I like silly and Murphy as well if
that's how you pronounce his name why
some people someone's gonna correct me
and say it's Killian all right
riddle solve yeah I can hear it I just
solved the riddle you know your dad died
but only in my hallucination I'm fine
had a little run-in with scarecrow
slowed me down I'll get back to you in a
bit okay well on to the next boss fight
this single section of the game is so
bizarre because it just packs scenes so
much stuff in the course of 15 minutes
all right you go you go straight from an
encounter with scarecrow right into the
next guy which I don't know I mean can I
spoil stuff in this game Velen care is
is there anyone who hasn't played this
I appreciate that they took the time to
animate this guy on the other side of
the door even though they didn't have to
do that a lead-pipe I love those hold on
could you just give me a second
okay here we go what's your opinion on
the females Clone Saga the female and
clone in the club whatever well I mean
Ultimate Universe Jessica drew which is
alright this is a girl clone of Peter um
I feel like Bendis didn't really know
what to do with that character after
introducing her so she just kind of
bounced around from one thing to the
next and ended up not getting really
used for anything
Spidey 7 I apologize you asked your
question one last time and I'll actually
look at the chat here here all I'll stop
the whole gal set down the controller
ask your question do you think it's
tiring to see a lot of humor in the MCU
movies I mean spider-man makes sense but
for three basically needed a win I'm a
little tired of sense of humor and the
the MCU it's you know I could pick up
this secrets map but I don't need it I'm
an MLG Batman player this light this uh
I mean you guys have seen how well the
speedrun there's no death speedrun on a
hardest difficulty is going so far and
basically the best ever at this game
Smasher pass Harley Quinn why not both
would you prefer the 50 cent or Deadpool
games to the annual series what oh oh to
be annual series there's a 50 cent
series what I remember there's 50 cent
blood on the sand or some [ __ ] that was
like like some vanity video game project
where the rapper 50 cent was running
around like invading the Middle East for
some reason
part of me is revving it dreading having
to play spider-man ps4 because of how
much I suck oh boy I know how you feel
at that Savior go back and pick it up
don't don't kid yourself yeah
if there's one thing I'm good at in this
game it's finding the stupid Riddler
trophies Martha
yeah Martha sure is a thing that exists
unfortunately
I'm doing pretty good with this one I'm
gonna turn my head there's gonna be a
guy right there that's gonna shoot me in
the nethers you this I do not turn
around that is my only request okay
thank you
you know Harley Quinn sure is like a
little bit not vigilant right now she
could just take a peek out the window
and see everyone's laying on the ground
unconscious she could have probably
actively seen me strangling a dude but
you know the best way to be a security
guard is to stare directly at the thing
you're trying to protect and nowhere
else who is better renegade spider-man
or bomb squad aren't they the same thing
watch watch it before you judge
considering you say basically it's a
comedy me Thor you see I don't know I'm
just worried about Thor 3 I'm really
worried I'm I'm not gonna enjoy it be
cool just like I'm having that fear of
with like every Marvel movie lately like
I I get American sidered not seeing
homecoming in the theater that's how bad
it's getting I'm that bored with these
movies now there's me review tape in
here hold on never mind that
get behind me no well Batman you could
probably hack into it
Baine those clothes are way too big for
you you look silly Smasher pass Ben
Riley oh definitely smash only if the
hoodie is involved weird how bein in
this game seems to be like a completely
different character for Bane and Arkham
origins playing these games
chronologically just doesn't work Arkham
origins does not lead into this game
well enough I mean it works fine on its
own but as a prequel that this is just
weird like it works better as a prequel
to Arkham City bizarrely enough
Jim Gordon regenerates with every Batman
Arkham game because he looks different
every single - yeah pretty much
he's kind of like the doctor all right
hold on let's see if I can do this fight
well enough yeah well I attempted to
throw a Batarang and turned on Detective
mode check it out I'm gonna do this
fight without taking a single bit of
damage it's gonna be awesome everyone's
gonna be so proud of me everyone's gonna
be so impressed they'll be like wow
Savior you're so good at video games we
like you so much what was that what did
he just do is his knee there that was so
silly it was like he was like breaking a
stick over his knee that didn't exist
out my face oh my face again can you
just give me a second holy [ __ ] out talk
[ __ ] get hit huh fair enough I practice
on myself I'm afraid to go get near him
after that last thing hi hey I'm worried
I don't want to get close to him now
because that hurts so bad oh come on
that's enough
that's cheating no one said you could do
that in this totally fair fist fight
that we're having he did the knee thing
again okay is he gesturing like I'm
gonna snap you over my knee like
remember that time I did that thing
oh god I hope Azrael doesn't show up and
become basically me but the Punisher
again from that time as a real Batman
and Punisher hung out and all they did
was talk about how shitty they both
thought Bruce Wayne was and they were
just like like bestest buddies because
they both loved murder so much that's a
lot of things that I can't really fight
without getting hit hello God okay I'm
just gonna ah my shoulder I did the
thing well that was unfortunate if I
started screaming a little bit earlier
would everyone be able to show up again
tomorrow wait we could probably like
beat this game in the course of about a
week okay this time for real though ah
ah the Sun was in my eyes no fair okay
hold on hold on catch at Tee tee time
out we got to establish some ground
rules the safety word is Damian
because nothing ruins the mood more than
Damian Wayne Oh
okay all right I'm apparently a it's
just it's just gonna this is how it's
gonna be I'm gonna have to beat this
this fight without getting my magic
pixel of health taken away Batman mini
needs to deliver more pizzas tomorrow's
a school night no it isn't tomorrow
Sunday or unless you're on the other
side of that International Dateline
that's extremely confusing is it Sunday
for some people
okay hold on okay hold on all right
let's just one thing at a time maybe I
can just hope that Bane takes them all
out ah okay all right that that was not
I'm not the only person who's getting
sick of people calling spider-man iron
boy or iron man junior and homecoming I
don't know maybe beat him out Hank would
be this way I'm gonna do to you what
Hank does to jannat pain I'm gonna
ignore you a lot that's for sure I'm
gonna punch you in the nethers
do you think the Titan formula makes
everything big you look bigger like or
is it like a normal steroid where it
only works on like muscles pain hold on
I have a very important question for you
regarding your eye you know well I mean
that this might be a little below the
belt you know I'm saying but uh okay
here we go now we're doing it yeah it's
probably pretty late in England in angle
and I apologize people who live overseas
it's very late for you well I'm
surprised I'm not dead from that he just
threw like a 50 like 50 ton chunk of
concrete at me I'd that guy I should
probably be dead
someone throw a punch so I can okay
nevermind Oh Xavier upgrade your [ __ ]
that's a great idea why is bein an idiot
in these games when he's established
when it's established he's a master
strategist well you know this series has
a real problem with boss fights hey
everyone I turned on Detective mode when
I was trying to throw a Batarang again
here let's um yeah let's just
yeah let's um keep keep killing this Wow
TNS I donated 20 not America dollars I
was genuinely nearly named after a
sports channel because of my dad and
it's 3:50 a.m. on a Sunday here in
Ireland ah dude I appreciate you being
here I know that it's probably pretty
damn late but still it's it's nice
having you and I appreciate the donation
you're a swell dude and and thank you
thank you much
all donations are appreciated everyone
thank you so far thank you to everyone
who's donated to the stream so far it's
great of you you're all lovely people
did that count as me dodging see the
trick to fight him is to treat him like
any Dark Souls enemy just punch him in
the butt over and over remember that
time in the Batman the Batman when when
Joker injected himself with all kinds of
Titans formula venom or whatever so he
could be like Bane and he was like this
big and he was just running around smash
and stuff and then Batgirl beat him up I
think oh okay hold on ah you know I hate
when you try to do the ground takedown
thing but you're too far away so Batman
just does this really goofy thing out he
does this really goofy thing like he's
up can I dodge yes
okay all right
I'm got him on the ropes I'm doing great
he has this really weird move where it
looks like he's like doing some kind of
Jazzercise thing you know he does this
look I'm exercising
maybe that should become like the new
Batman t-bag is this weird move or he's
kind of like crouching but also like
doing it doing this this pullback motion
lazar what look at this what is this can
you do this and like get get a decent
amount of exercise from it no I was
trying to dodge is there like a way to
cancel after you're in the middle of a
move just cuz um if I use it okay Bane
if you can help me out here and beat up
some of these guys it would be greatly
appreciated
yeah yeah do that thank you yeah it's
just the best he's such an help the guy
wait no great hold on oh right as I was
complimenting Xavier you just beat the
[ __ ] out of the thugs don't need to r1
on that you left a penny on the floor
yeah that's that's the motion Batman's
doing Batman workout press Y to lose
weight
well Batman's got a workout for like 15
hours a day to stay in this kind of
shape
whoa did the thing again maybe I should
just tape down the l2 button so I'll
just stop pressing it
here we go yeah do it whole and then
we're gonna do a thing why is he just
laughing maniacally I don't get it you
just smashed face-first into a wall what
are you so just laughing cuz it's so
funny that you smashed your face into a
wall they never give a good enough
reason for people laughing maniacally
other than the Joker you know sometimes
it just seems so out of place all right
back to doing my training yeah wait Han
Bane you were like the least least
helpful workout buddy around
now oh hey my upgrades doomsday hold on
one sec Darth gamer oh you're going to
sleep see you around buddy thank you for
showing up we appreciate having you
after the stream I recommend you check
check out this YouTube youtuber called
Diamond bolt okay I could try that how
big is the incredible hulks dick you
know I feel like there's a joke in
Mallrats about this but then again that
could be applied to most things oh wait
wait stop doing that stop doing that
thing that you're doing
Wow thanks for throwing that concrete at
that guy Bane you killed him so I don't
have to because I'm Batman and I don't
kill people
Batman doesn't kill people people kill
people you know Bane I feel like your
legs are maybe a little bit
disproportionate to the rest of your
body as is your head it's kind of
off-putting really I mean I'm sure
someone out there is into that look but
I I don't know I'm not I'm not feeling
good you know I it's weird that Bane
could probably grab his entire head in
his hand because I've got a titan
formula proportions on your body get all
wonky with this stuff
okay that was helpful is he talking to
me or the criminals
[Music]
ow okay Bain throw throw a piece of
concrete at these guys just so you know
they feel bad for messing with me if I
lame it out I can just let him beat them
all up for me that Batarang not land or
did that hit something else whoop just
gonna hop on over here I really wish I
had my uh there's this ability from the
other games that I really loved was the
bat clock quick select thing where you
could just in the middle of a fight
randomly tug a guy towards you with the
back law and then just started wailing
on him I really like that feature and I
wish it out let me hit you more stop
doing the thing that you're doing okay
that's fair I'm just gonna hop out of
the way here oh my god I didn't know he
could turn I thought he had to just go
in one direction and keep with it
you were born in the darkness but I grew
up in it so you know there's that yeah
we did it shouldn't the batarangs cut
veins tubes well no but the batarangs
can't cut through it it's too powerful
but Batman's your physical strength with
his hand can come to us that's something
totally different
Xavier do you wish you could just cut
Bane's tubes and win like Batman always
does in a fight with bane yeah yeah do
you think who do you think would win
Joker Heath Ledger or penny wise bill
scars gotta find you I mean one of
them's like a weird supernatural being
and the other one just doesn't really
care like I feel like it would be kind
of a weird stalemate because Joker can't
really be scared like he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's immune to fear toxin mood you
rather have helped you beat up skip
Westcott Dan slaughter Zack Snyder or
Dan Schneider well you know Dan
Schneider um until you know the sexual
harassment allegations come out against
him in the media he seems like the
nicest of the bunch
I'm waiting any any day now for the news
that he did something bad Dan Schneider
it's gonna be there any second check
Twitter right now there's probably news
about Dan Schneider being a diddle man
Jim get back to the main line it's too
dangerous
Bane from origins and Bane from asylum
is like carnage and venom and one is
better than the other radio claims if I
read any Stephen King books no but I do
have a lot because my dad used to
collect them and now I just have like
this whole bookshelf that's Spanish
which what is your point what is your
opinion on the disappointment of
returned to Arkham which one was that
again go through the city's computer
oh the the HD re-release I'll go through
anything you know I didn't play it I
mean it's just the same games but with a
retexture I could just play the old one
just lay my head for situations like
this do I collect comics well I try to I
mean if it's like comics I really like
I'll try and get a physical copy but I
read a lot of mine digitally you tales
channel you didn't answer my question
oh I'm sorry what was your question were
once the venom and that can only be
trouble I'm heading to dead man's point
in Arkham North I'll contact you once
I'm in the Batcave
boy you show a lot of people in this
game sure do end up underwater I am
buying returned to Arkham tomorrow oh
okay well not me the person who typed
that in the chat oh wow I can actually
just keep going while it's playing
that's handy TK Tyler has a question go
for a man what do you got
have you watched a red JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure yet no not yet I would like to
I have had a friend describe it to me in
great detail and it sounds awesome but
uh there just to be thorough let's make
sure there's three batt logos it's just
just so they really know all the people
who aren't going to see this because I'm
blowing up this wall well a lot of audio
logs around here what do you think of
axel Alonso
not a fan kana don't like anyone who's
like really in charge of Marvel right
now I think they could all take a hike
okay TK Thalia I answered that question
king arcane says he has a dumb question
well there are no dumb questions only
dumb answers and that's on me
who would you rather have helped you
beat up skip Wescott Dan Slott Zack
Snyder or Dan Schneider I already
answered that one it was Dan Schneider
you know just because like probably ask
him questions about like Drake and Josh
that'd probably be it focusing on
punching people
while talking it's hard I just
superheroes talk and punch so well
it's like tiring in a video game but in
real life I could only imagine it being
very exhausting mentally anyway
Batman returned Arkham is actually a
substantial improvement
unlike most you know I don't know I I
forgot again some very mixed opinions on
it some people say that it looks worse
some people say it's not worth the money
I I don't know Jessica Rome Owen asks
can I read this comet do you mean
comment with an N
so bats Joker I have some questions you
know you have several of these dummies
built around around the island that look
like you primarily in this area uh how
did you manage to get so many great
duplicates of your outfit to put it put
it in here and like are you just sitting
around the corner setting them up and
then talking into a TV
I know later this is actually just a
helmet so how does that function you
can't just cut a hole in the bottom of a
TV and then put it on your head I mean
it's not the real Joker currently
because sometimes he'll come back here
let me show you sometimes you'll come
back and there's like ten of them in
there
all right dumb fan theory time Joker was
a hallucination from the very beginning
and Batman actually has taken over the
island it's pronounced Ramone I
apologize
see there's another one right here which
one of you is the real Joker which one
do I shoot Xavier what is your favorite
superhero team I like the Thunderbolts a
lot they were really cool like the the
Daniel way one that was launched a
couple years back with Punisher Deadpool
Red Hulk venom Flash Thompson venom
Elektra that was just such a cool lineup
for a team like so many great characters
all in one place and I thought that was
interesting I'm a little sad that that
series ended and then they replaced
Thunderbolts with something a little bit
more traditional to the original premise
because Thunderbolts to my knowledge is
just like basically Suicide Squad
yeah yeah they're basically suicides
fine oh I thought I could climb up that
ledge blub did I just say glub
well that's let's do a swan dive into
this water I go oh a trophy in your
opinion which superhero has the best
cast of villains it is probably a tie
between spider-man and Batman they both
have really great villains oh I forgot I
need the stupid line launcher thing to
get over there
Godzilla are you going to finish the
dead space serious you've only got up to
Episode seven well you know I could
probably just livestream it now I suck
and I'm soaked who's here what huh oh
hello friends would you like to play
which one of you would like to partake
in a friendly game of pinochle how about
you sir care to partake I see you'd
rather play a rousing game of fisticuffs
I must warn you I'm rather well-versed
in the arts of hand-to-hand combatants
anyway Xavier what's your favorite game
of Batman probably this one I haven't
played that Batman Begins one from 2005
but I kinda wanna do I enjoy Marvel vs.
Capcom I've only played two and infinite
because I played them at this game and
convention thing that Josh took me to
like two weeks ago and those were both
pretty cool I'm you know I understand
why a lot of people are really pissed
about Marvel vs. Capcom intranet but it
didn't seem that bad what are these good
spider-man villains most seem to be
normal years normal generic criminals of
powers are you serious dude oh really
you haven't read stuff with like vermin
he's a pretty cool one you know Green
Goblin is great basically spider-man's
Joker venom is not really a villain so
much anymore as he is like an antihero
I think Doc Ock has his moments
San mana is interesting to me because
he's also more of an antihero like
Sandman stop being just a straight-up
villain kind of quick and went more for
like this like tragic hero who's doing
bad stuff you know event for a while
Sandman was on the Avengers no one
remembers that [ __ ] oh hang on okay what
all right everyone
it would really help me if you could
just start telegraphing your moves with
a blue electric lightning bolt thing on
your head
that would really help me right now if
you could just just start doing that
that would be great
oh god this bush is in the way I can't
see I'm trying so hard to be funny right
now while I'm playing and I'm just
getting my ass kicked like an idiot I
punched that guy in the crotch I don't
know what just happened there I tried to
throw a Batarang and then I just kind of
like Detective moated again oh that
fight was terrible vermin is very
underrated if he Rita both Cravens last
hunt and child within both by the same
author those are great stories there is
some of the darkest ones for Spidey
child within especially carnage is just
kind of I mean he's cool he's very cool
don't get me wrong but in terms of
actual personality he's a little flat
because he's just kind of just the Joker
really I mean without the sense of
theatrics like Joker likes killing
people via elaborate death trap or like
moral decision effects carnage just cuts
people's heads off what is your favorite
Spider Man my favorite spider-man is
Noir I've always wanted to know Xavier I
really like spider-man 2099 and the
reason for that is because he's such a
depart departure from normal spider-man
stories there's just you know that's
that's the thing about 2099 that's cool
and makes him unique to me is that he is
not at all like just a reskin of Peter
Parker it's the same as how Batman
Beyond is not just Bruce Wayne jr. in a
literal sense well I mean a figurative
sense is I like when you do a legacy
character that is not just a duplicate
of the last guy but at the same time not
when the character lacks any kind of
drama or interesting hook like I would
say a negative examples like Amadeus Cho
is the Hulk he can control his powers so
what's really like the conflict he's
just he's incredibly smart and
incredibly strong and he can just turn
off when he's going on when he's doing
the strong thing so what like what's
what's the source of drama for Amadeus
Cho stories other than just generic
teenage superhero trying to be exactly
like spider-man
oh no proms tomorrow but I also got to
stop this super villain what do I do
um any hopes for the Batman film I don't
know man it's kind of all up in the air
at this point I mean they had a lot of
they had some cool promises for it oh
definitely get 2099 classic it's it's
worth your time doing on the arc Miguel
O'Hara is a great carrot
the new Batman movie I don't know what
to expect they keep saying different
things about what's gonna even be in it
I'm just hoping it isn't bad I kind of
wanted it to be a Red Hood story but
then they made it seem like they were
gonna try and adapt Arkham and then they
were gonna make it seem like something
it had something to do a Deathstroke but
then they I think they just kind of like
had no idea what to do with Deathstroke
they cast him they have his costume done
they have a guy who's like excited to
play him and would probably do pretty
good at it
but then they're like oh [ __ ] where do
we even put him because him being a
Justice League would be too weird we
don't know about having him be in the
stupid Batman movie he can't be in
Suicide Squad too so they at the very
last minute decided to announce that
he's getting his own film
did you watch enjoy spider-man unlimited
I watched it but men do not necessarily
enjoyed it I mean I tolerate it it's a
thing that exists it's not bad it's just
kind of I mean I don't know it feels
like if they tried to adapt 2099 and
then just didn't do it well enough
I mean it's spider-man trapped on a
weird furry planet of people who call
themselves beasts heels and like people
who aren't creepy furry people are
considered the underclass
[Music]
just not really my bag no I'm not in it
thoughts on twisted metal series in a
retrospective like do you want me to do
a retrospective series like review all
of them or do you want me to just tell
you my thoughts here to advertise the
YouTube channel okay I have no idea why
I want to read that's one outlet kind of
blows my mind how much I didn't realize
that this is the same voice actor as
warden sharp like I totally just you
just didn't make the connection it's so
obvious now
any funny bloopers when I'm doing
spider-man rushers when doing okay um I
don't really have a lot of funny
bloopers that I remember from the
spider-man retrospective oh wow and bad
gaming Thank You holy crap
$20 I am so distracted right now by your
generosity that I'm getting hit in the
face repeatedly oh god yeah I just thank
you I really appreciate it um it's great
of you oh I keep getting hit in the face
okay back to the focusing uh I'm trying
to think of anything from the like
development of the spider-man game
retrospective that would be worth
talking about I mean really the story
behind those reviews is actually kind of
sad
um I don't know if you guys would want
to even know why it wise started doing
those
ha geez
huh you know I know it's just like
random NPC generation but it is you
don't find it well like a little weird
that only one of them was black
oh Diego Rivera $10 hey Xavier good to
see streaming will these be regular or a
spur-of-the-moment I want to start
making these be a regular thing now that
I finally have OBS more or less figured
out on my own
I would love to start doing these more
commonly and it's just nice to talk to
you guys directly not having to like you
know reply to a billion Twitter comments
or whatever just just talking to you
like this
I would like to do another one of these
tomorrow and maybe Monday if I can find
time do you got a record the podcast
tomorrow so we'll see if I have time for
it but uh yeah these are definitely
gonna be more regular I want to know I
would like to know all right well uh you
guys don't mind me getting a little bit
personal I'm I'll probably finish this
up at the three hour mark so I'll tell
you a quick story um so the reason that
I started doing the spider-man game
retrospectives is because I really just
needed something to take my mind off of
how life was going at the time as if
like what like mid-2015 I think is when
I started those around that time I uh oh
by the way Killer Croc hi jump-scare
buddy
man what a cool guy him and Bane should
fight um
so around midway through 2015 I was
dating this girl who was kind of mean or
actually extremely mean she was very
emotionally abusive and she cheated on
me with a guy named Patrick and then he
found me and then bragged about it to me
and I was really depressed and I was
like god I need it I need something to
take my mind off of life right now cuz
that was like the first girlfriend I had
ever had it was just going so poorly so
I was like is there something I can do
to just like kill some time maybe I can
make like a youtube video about
something that no one cares about so of
course being that I loved video games
and I loved comic books I decided to do
a game review and I'd done a couple of
like editorial sort of things that no
one watched but prior to that about like
Batman and spider-man those are just
kind of like practicing for the editing
but uh I I did the first retrospective
and it got like I don't like a hundred
and fifty views and I was like holy [ __ ]
that's a really successful video one
hundred and fifty views so it got me
excited to do another one uh fun fact is
I actually almost didn't do it because I
was having such a hard time figuring out
the frame rate on recording PlayStation
1 game footage because it looks so
choppy and ugly and I still to this day
have it like not a hundred percent
figured out it looked really bad and I
was like well I can't have the review
look like this everyone's just
complaining that the frame rate sucks
one of the reasons why the let's play of
ultimate spider-man had some problems is
because the this capture card software
just does not like games prior to ps3 or
xbox 360
so III first second considered not doing
it until I got it like kind of figured
out I mean it didn't look terrible but
it was still kind of noticeable history
so I did the review that way and
everyone you know like of the 150 people
who watched it I think like three of
them commented and liked it so I thought
I could do another one I mean it's just
something fun to do you know and of
course this this girlfriend of mine at
the time just had me so messed up that I
I had to figure out it like as many ways
as possible to take my mind off of like
all the shitty stuff she was doing so I
even like took time to write a novel
which I'm now trying to repurpose into a
comic book I am become pestilence which
is I don't know how to feel about that
title I might change it but I'm kind of
stuck with it for the moment I was up
until like 4:00 a.m. every night for god
knows how many months in 11:00 or in
tenth grade just writing and writing and
writing trying to forget this story
exactly right and I felt like a lot of
it I was just like I felt really pissed
off and angry and I had to get it out
some way so I wrote a story about a very
pissed-off an angry person with a lot of
pent-up problems so yeah a lot of the
you know when when eventually we get I
am become pestilence you know public
release either published through a
company or however we end up doing it
you'll be you'll probably be able to see
that there was a lot of pain put into it
while I was writing it just you know a
lot of what was happening to me at the
time kind of bled in and the story is
not necessarily about any of that stuff
but you could just tell by the tone of
it that it was kind of inspired by
something sad so you know yeah yeah yeah
that's the thing
well let me keep scrolling down sorry I
kinda was focusing on the game for a
second oh that's why you seem so
depressed in that video well yeah yeah
pretty much um that that and also just
because I wasn't really good at talking
on camera yet even today I still think I
have some issues but when you're
recording a video and trying to you know
sounds charismatic and sound excited
it's just not something that comes super
naturally for me so it took a couple of
tries I still think by the time I got to
maybe um the Arkham Knight review was
when my voice was okay to listen to
prior to that it sounded kind of like
dry and dull but that was the one I was
like the first one I was really happy
with the way it sounded oh I just got
shot in the shoulder hold on just give
me a sec I just want to go over okay
what's your favorite corn album um you
know I really like issues but um hmm
follow-the-leader is also really good I
don't know I mean I like a lot of I
don't think there's a single one I
dislike except kind of maybe path of
totality just because it tried so hard
to push into this weird dubstep
direction and there's a couple of songs
on there that I really don't like hold
on guys don't spoil the fact that I'm
gonna go ledge take down this guy just
just wait down there here we go it was
very polite of them not to warn this guy
you know sometimes you got to wonder is
the world full of shitty people but then
you see stuff like that where these two
hardened criminals betray each other
while over a man at a bat costume
attacks them viciously with physical
pain and you just think yeah the world
is full of shady people
wait what was I trying to say again did
I just hit two people at once that was
bizarre hey Xavier that contest in spot
contest of slashers inspired webhead
issue is coming along four pages done so
far oh that's awesome dude yeah did I
mean I'd keep it going I'm a little sad
that contest of slashers is taking as
long as it is to come out but you know
we that's the thing is that was uh kind
of a that project I think was destined
to take a long-ass time we should have
waited a lot longer before announcing it
because basically the entire creative
team is different now except for the
writer it's still a very long ways off
yes you know we still we got a different
artist we got a different colorist far
to guess when it would even start coming
along like really well I would say
expect a pretty solid update by like the
first month of 2018 just because the
artist was working on so many other
projects right now a couple of which are
for me the other ones I'm working with
how long have I listened to Korn pretty
much my entire life I've listened to
that band just because that's like
something that my mom was so into when
she was a punk 90s teenager my mom is
very much a gen Xer and listened to all
kinds of music like that she watched
beavis and butt-head on MTV she read
x-men comics in the 90s my mom read
x-men comics in the 90s and she thought
wow Xavier is a really cool name if I
have a kid I should name him Xavier and
then um that happened do i watch
stranger things yep
I'm just finished the second season I'm
pretty happy with it Xavier do upgrades
that's a good idea I should do upgrades
um oh oh oh I accidentally just hit the
button to upgrade I didn't want to I
wanted to get the health upgrade now I
feel like an idiot this is what happens
I reach out while I'm supposed to be
doing other things this is so much
harder without Josh here - just read the
chat for me
that bastard ends up going to college
and you're not staying behind
specifically to only scream with me all
day
well how selfish of him getting an
education what I what a jerk how old are
you Xavier I am 19 I know I act a lot of
younger than that I always thought you
were named after Professor X well yeah a
dude who loves comic books and is named
after a comic-book character here are
all cut down these bodies just you know
this is not really so much for as like a
respect thing just these corpses will be
less gross if they're not hanging upside
down because the blood will start to
pool in their skulls and eventually the
skin will just burst and whose brains
and blood will fall all over the places
it's it's more so out of respect to the
person who has to clean up all these
corpses what do you think of serenity of
suffering it's I mean a lot of people
keep saying it sounds like a classic
Korn album like something right out of
the stuff they are doing in the 90s but
to me it sounds almost exactly like
something like like they're untitled
album or what's that other one god I'm
starting to forget the titles because
there's so many it sounds a lot more
like stuff they were doing in the year
2000 and onward then it does of
something they were doing in like the
90s but it's not bad it's just not quite
like the ultimate classic thing everyone
saying you know that guy shot me
directly in the hand and somehow I still
left fingers
can you just let me climb up oh my god
ah
Xavier why do you know that know what
paradigm shift that's what it was yeah
it sounds a lot like that since since
you were playing Arkham what songs do
you think represent each Batman villain
well I don't know I mean I'd have to
really think on that one do I prefer
Tobey Maguire or Tom Holland to
spider-man
I don't know uh I don't know I guess Tom
just because I like that he's a little
bit more believable as someone young and
I he's a little bit better equips it's
kind of hilarious to me that people
barely talk about Andrew Garfield
anymore it's now become which do you
like Tom or Tobey no one talks about
Andrew like his whole take on spider-man
has kind of been forgotten and I think
that's very symptomatic of the how those
movies turned out not necessarily his
performance how do you feel about before
Watchmen as a concept oh by speedy do it
all it was nice having you sorry that
you have to leave but I think thank you
for showing up and stopping by it was
nice oh my god I'm getting sniped
because I'm too busy reading Chad how do
I get down oh my god oh my god that was
bad um well I was answering a question
oh how do I feel about before Watchmen
is a concept you know if a writer comes
up with a story and then is very adamant
about how that story is treated I think
it's
you know that's the sort of thing that
should be respected if the guy who wrote
Watchmen doesn't want you to make a seat
wall that's on him I don't think me and
maybe you should make a sequel if he
thinks that a prequel is unnecessary
maybe don't do a prequel you know just
like respect someone's story granted he
created a lot of really interesting and
cool characters and it's a shame to have
their story end so quickly after only
just a couple of issues because there's
a lot you can do with the Watchmen
universe but like throw up to me as
someone also asked how I am become
pestilence is coming along in the comic
it's going pretty great honestly I
really like the team I have assembled
for it they're all very professional
very reliable guys we have about one
page almost or we have one page done and
it's like page 19 of the first issue and
then we have most of page 1 done so
we're you know it's kind of a lengthy
process but it's coming along nicely as
soon as we have a couple of good ones
you know in order like one through five
or something we could probably send our
pitch to the publishers and see what
they have to say here I'm gonna try and
run and hope I don't get shot
hey snipers guess what you can't hit me
if I'm running it's impossible to hit a
moving target everyone knows that uh hey
Xavier what's your opinion on the
defenders kind of underwhelming sadly I
mean it was cool seeing these characters
interacting but it was kind of like I
don't know just I feel like it could
have been a little bit more exciting
than it was like the story started to
just kind of run out of steam at a
certain point I I think this problem
with a lot of the Netflix shows is that
they go a little bit longer than they
need to and I was like hoping that one
wouldn't have that problem because it's
only eight episodes but even then that
one started to feel like he was getting
he was getting a little long in the
tooth
do you take pay your team because I want
to create a comic
well here's the thing is all of us are
kind of working for free right now on
our various jobs because we want to get
it published
so you know once it starts getting in
the in the stores and it's actually
being sold we'll get paid but for the
moment right now like I'm writing just
for fun the artists or art ingest for
fun the colorist is coloring just for
fun right now it's mostly just a fun
project for us to sharpen up our skills
in every aspect of comics working and
then once we finally have our pitch
ready for a publisher and we get
accepted then we can start worrying
about you know getting everyone paid but
you know that's still we we got to get
at least like I don't know like I think
six consecutive pages of art done as
well as maybe lettering just so we have
something to show for what we've been
working on comic companies they kind of
expect a very detailed pitch when you
ask them if you can you know have them
publish your [ __ ] so they want like a
couple of script pages some consecutive
pages of art they need to know if like
who's doing what and how many people you
have on the team I think something
that'll set us a little bit apart is
that we have someone for everything like
we actually have someone coloring it
writing it doing the art you know doing
the the letters we don't have one of the
jobs going unfilled so they'd have to
find someone like contracts someone to
help do it for us we just be able to do
it for them really all they'd be doing
is just printing it we have everything
else coming who do you think is the best
Marvel villain Marvel character I like a
lot of Marvel characters I mean I don't
know if I can necessarily just sit down
and tell you which one's the best one
well spider-man's the the best Marvel
character in a sense that I think his
story
is the most interesting to me I like how
you can press the alternate fire
this and get like a POV shot for no
reason what's the point of that other
than it looks cool does it need a point
other than looking cool no okay my
connection is really messed up right now
I'm not sure if I can keep spamming and
the internet is blowing up I'm not sure
probably spider-man for most of us as
most of us found him through spider-man
videos America Chavez oh boy yeah
holy menstruation this is how normal
people talk in real life what a great
character do you think Rocksteady can
make a really great predator game oh
hell yeah dude they basically have it
like done you just got a reskin Batman
and take out the and just add like some
gore you jus daun there you go game game
makes itself you call it concrete jungle
to concrete jungle 2 jungle ow ah stop
kicking me for the love of God my
kidneys ah geez I set off the metal
detector
I like how to separate guys both said
that's gotta hurt it's almost like
they're like cheering me on
while I'm beating up their friends I
know these guys friends do you think any
of these guys like know each other by
name are they just purely working for
doping how do you get to work for the
Joker like the guy is like a known
terrorist and basically everything he
does fails miserably and he ends up in
prison how do you look at that guy and
go yeah that's someone I should work for
like these aren't down-on-their-luck
like criminals having a hard time with
the economy these guys all have to just
be flat-out sociopaths with very little
you know concern for risk versus reward
cuz working for Joker to take over the
city it's a lot of risk for very little
reward I mean it best all of you can
like maybe like I don't know like I mean
maybe if you're like won it like his
right-hand man I could see you getting
like all kinds of money and [ __ ] but if
you're just random thug number 48 how
much are you really being promised by
the Joker how does even pay the people
who work for him like I can't imagine
the Joker just like writing out a check
so he'd have to just give people stacks
of cash that was stolen what's the worst
new Marvel character there's a lot of
them that are pretty bad Hey look
everyone I'm gonna do my Wolverine
impression hey I get it get it cuz he
has a lighter in his pocket because he
has a C as a smoking problem
there's something so addictive about
Riddler trophies like I would play a
whole game that's just looking for
Riddler trophies and solving puzzles as
long as the Batmobile wasn't involved I
was actually like probably one of my
favorite lines of dialogue from the
Riddler and all three of these games
why doesn't Robin sneak into Arkham and
help because um he's he's busy busy not
helping
technically Arkham Knight has his origin
story on this island somewhere in a room
that we never see at any point and also
Batman for some reason has no idea how
how he got there
hey can I have a quick little rant
Arkham Knight apologists need to stop
making up reasons for why that game
makes sense because if the game doesn't
explicitly tell you how a thing works
then coming up with your own logic to
make it make sense is not how the story
is good do not tell me that the Joker
planned to have him be have himself be a
hallucination for Batman and
specifically did something with the
Titan formula to make that happen that
doesn't make sense
that's just like a super giant leaf in
logic and there's nothing to even give
the impression that says that's a thing
you can also say that like well you know
he's not actually a hallucination he's
like just an actual ghost at one point
in this entire game series is anything
genuinely supernatural happened and also
I find it a little suspicious that you
only see this ghost character while
under the influence of a dangerous
hallucinogen that makes you see your
worst fear so in short Arkham Knight is
still stupid and all of the excuses
given make no sense and people need to
stop trying so hard to figure out how
that game
works because it doesn't it just it
doesn't favorite Fallout game I know a
lot of people hate it but I didn't have
a bad time with fallout 3 granted it's
kind of like it's extremely linear and
gives you like very crap choices in the
way of like being a an RPG but I thought
it was fun
Arkham Knights story doesn't make sense
but I like it anyway hey you know that's
okay though if you like Arkham Knights
if you just if you like Arkham Knight
that's fine
I've never at any point told anyone they
can't like something you know if if
there's something about it that I don't
like I'll express it in a video but that
doesn't mean that no one's allowed to
have their own opinion on it and that's
the thing that I think a lot of
reviewers kind of forget about is they
have to remember that their opinion is
their own like something that's put me
off - like your movie sucks that channel
there's been a couple of times where
he's just stated his opinion like it's a
flat out objective fact like when he was
reviewing edge of tomorrow and he goes
this movie's not as good as everyone
says it is what what good or bad is
subjective if people like it they like
it you can't tell them they're wrong can
you make a Noricum retrospective I
actually explained why I would not do
that in the very beginning of the Batman
Arkham Knight review I would have like
nothing to say that guy is looking right
at me hey you play any of the Metroid
games
unfortunately I played metroid other m
and that was it well also one of them on
the Gameboy but I can't remember which
it was like Super Metroid or something
zavier Gotham season 1 and season 2 were
decent Riddler and Penguin were both
solid except for penguin who
turned out gay I always figured the
penguin was gay I never really had a
problem with that part I mean he dresses
like angry he's Danny DeVito you know I
don't know Gotham to me just I wasn't
into it
whoa excuse me sir hold on wait no hold
on please wait no just can't we just
talk about this man this movies so fake
you could see how his kick didn't land
at all you know I have a really bad
story about when I watched the first
Rocky movie is that the punches were so
far off from hitting that for a while I
thought Rocky was dodging all of those
hits at the final act of that movie and
then the announcer kept saying he's
really taking a pounding I'm like no
he's not all of those are missing it's
like super obvious isn't it I genuinely
thought he was just missing but no you
know they didn't do the thing from like
Cinderella Man where the elite actor was
like okay I want to make sure you
actually hit me in the face as many
times as possible so it looks real does
she keep her records there Xavier do you
think there should be a Serie A
spider-man series like Gotham what would
that be about would it just be like a
ten-year-old nerdy Peter Parker and like
the conflict of the first season is that
he gets attacked by by skip Westcott and
then his parents died in a plane crash
and then Uncle Ben teaches him about
responsibility like what would a
spider-man Gotham be about no one cares
about what spider-man was doing before
he got bit by the spider that's the
boring part no one cares what Bruce
Wayne was doing before he learned a
billion martial arts and how to be the
world's smartest person
I'm sure the show isn't terrible but I
have some problems with the premise did
you hear that YMS sent his fans to hate
on a channel because they didn't like it
comes at night ha I did not hear that
now I want to give him the benefit of
the benefit of the doubt and assume he
didn't intentionally say hey everyone go
spam this channel with bad comments
because they have a different opinion
maybe he just specifically said like
said he disagreed with that Channel and
they you know I know fan bases can
sometimes get a little little wacky and
do their own crazy stuff when will this
stream end well I was gonna end it at 3
hours but then it like it's been 9 extra
minutes and I still have no idea what
I'm doing this is probably good spot to
end it just standing up on this really
high bookshelf I had a good time thank
you everyone for the donations those
were awesome I appreciate it everyone
you're all great people gaming central
here's your shoutout a young Bruce Wayne
and Alfred series in a similar similar
to Tintin would be neat yeah I guess as
long as they're actually going on
adventures instead of just sitting in
their house all day arguing about stuff
oh wow he actually commented on someone
else's video and said to go hate on
those guys that's kind of shitty what do
you think of the rumors of the
supposedly upcoming Batman game being
developed by WB games well hold on first
I have to ask you what's wrong with this
thing can anyone hear me hello is anyone
there
you're supposed to say it now cash that
close enough but anyway um yeah I I had
a great time hopefully we can do this
again tomorrow if Aaron's not like
staying up too too late um I don't have
school on Monday thankfully so I'll be
old stay up late
so yeah I'll just um well we'll end the
stream in this vent I bet these guys are
looking around going why the [ __ ] is
Batman just hiding in this vent what is
wrong with him what is he doing what's
wrong uh him I said what's wrong with
him and he said what's wrong with this
thing and like perfect unison hey cash
jinx you owe me a soda
Xavier can you break me a piece of that
KitKat bar oh yeah man here you go
saver does it bother you that in the MCU
Tony Stark can literally replace
spider-man if he kept the suit he may
create his own web shooters and start
swinging around rooftops well I mean
you'd probably just break his arms
because you know the thing people don't
take into account about web-swinging is
that all the sudden stops and changes in
directions would probably make most
people's organs explode out of their
face but spider-man's got like extremely
dense bones and muscles and organs like
he's just that's why he can get thrown
through a brick wall and not explode
into guts is because he's tough right um
same for web-swinging I don't think any
random Schmo can just get a web shooter
and just go swinging you you jostle your
organs way too much you'd probably rip
your arm out of its socket you dislocate
your shoulder at best you know the
probably like not be able to switch
directions midair fast enough and then
the web line would just like kind of go
limp and you just fall
spider-man is only really capable of web
swinging via his powers I think that a
lot of people misconstrue it is just
like well he has the web-shooter if you
have the web-shooter you can swing it's
like no you also have to be extremely
fast and strong and agile um please
don't tell arachnid tech in the discord
server I told him that because he is
very dead set on making himself his own
spider-man costume and web shooters and
I'm very concerned for his physical
health I I believe he'll probably die in
a horrible web-swinging related accident
but anyway okay I should probably end it
now I've still been talking I need to
know wait hold on Jessica Ramon has one
last question amazing spider-man 2 or
spider-man 3 games yeah amazing
spider-man 2 because at least like like
one very small fraction of the gameplay
was fun and I like the alternate
costumes okay well I think I'll cut it
off here I had a great time with
everyone it was fun
everyone suggested me on Twitter what
game you think I should do after this
one I don't think I necessarily want to
do another Arkham game right away but
tell me something maybe you think would
be cool to watch alright see you around
everyone